there to the into the impossible podcast
featuring
a triality of guests a threesome of the
best kind i don't know if that's true
actually but uh i've heard i've heard
things from eric from eric no doubt uh
we're gonna be joining uh hundreds of
people are watching out there in youtube
lynn it's such a treat
whenever i gather with physicists to
share good ideas good company and so
forth let me get a thumbs up out there
if you guys uh can hear uh hear me and
i'm gonna introduce my friends
doctors two doctors actually three
doctors if you include me as well and
that is dr eric weinstein joining us
from los angeles how are you eric
doing well good to be with you
and it's nice of you to dress up unlike
garrett and myself i'm in the hawaiian
islands mood we just
finished what the hell he's not actually
playing brian
you can't get dolled up for me to talk
physics this is dolled up this is my
dress code nowadays this is island time
on shakalaka all right eric's enjoying
his vodka tonic and uh i am enjoying a
mai tai
over here uh in san diego and garrett
lisey welcome back
welcome back garrett
long time no see it's been about four
minutes
and you guys go way back as both friends
and friendly arch nemesis we're gonna
get into what does that actually mean
your infamous appearance on the portal
uh which was uh so well received and
this is kind of maybe a part two an
option for our guests on the into the
impossible family to ask some questions
about uh about different competing
theories of everything and as i said
earlier we're going to have a nice clean
fight we are going to go toe to toe
that's a good one toe-to-toe
i mean eric it looks like you've trimmed
down a bit did you end up adopting a
ketogenic diet or what have you been
doing you know garrett it looks like
you've been struggling a little bit i
think this has to do with some sort of a
block chain effect where whatever weight
i lose has to go over to you i'm sorry
to do that yeah i've definitely built up
the the covet 10. yeah conservation of
mass
how's the surf been this winter oh it's
been freaking fantastic yeah it's been
it's been really really good
um also we've had fewer tourists here
than normal which has actually been nice
if not for nice reasons yeah
yeah indeed maybe we'll talk about that
the impact on
on culture and physics as a whole uh
first i want to be i always like to be a
little bit provocative if i can uh
indulge be indulged by you two guys and
that's you know this conversation that
garrett and i had you know was sort of
predicated on this question that i
received a new book in the mail today
eric and it's entitled uh the theory of
everything by norbert schwertzer and
this is a very dense book uh it's full
of equations and graphs and i can't wait
to read it and put it next to uh you
know next to uh the the stack of books
behind me that i've been doing in
pandemic podcasting but uh why do we
need a theory of everything eric why is
it that people are so betwixt by
theories of everything and yet as
garrett and i just finished and you and
i have talked about there's less
attention to experiments of everything
why do you think that is
well first of all i don't know that it
makes sense to to
to say an experiment of everything one
of the crazy things that we found out
from our experimental friends
is that there is so much more order that
appears to be present in the standard
model and in general relativity
that
in a weird way all of these disparate
experiments have strangely added up to
something
unexpectedly coherent and so i don't
think it's important to focus on a
theory of everything generally because
you're usually not in position to get
one if you think about the time before
dirac
they knew about the proton and the
electron perhaps but they didn't know
about anything else and if they had
tried a theory of everything it would
have almost certainly been wrong because
there was just
no they were nowhere close now the
problem that we have here
is that we appear to be tantalizingly
close for reasons that we can get into
or not according to taste
and
i think that you know there's both a
silly hope that you happen to be in the
right generation to do a theory of
everything and an informed hope
and i think one of the things that that
you can tell when somebody attempts it
is do they appear to be well motivated
in seeking a theory of everything or do
they appear to just want to jump to the
end of the book no matter how many
chapters they have to skip over
and i you know i would also just say
lastly that um it's been so long since
we've made progress that it does sort of
one interpretation could that one could
make would be
that
we seem to be at a point where we have
to get something huge because we've been
stalled out with all the incremental
measures which in previous eras have
worked so well
and so one one way of thinking about
this is that we're finally at the point
where the conceptual difficulties like
what would a theory of everything even
mean
it's one thing to say that you're
hunting a jabberwocky it's another thing
to realize that you have no idea what a
jabberwocky looks like
and when i uh think about this
you know we talked a lot about our
mutual friend and i say that with all
sincerity dr sabina hasenfelder who does
great work and but as a known critic i
talked to garrett about this before
maybe you and i have talked about this
too eric uh in reference to uh professor
frank wilczyk's recent trolling of of
sabine last week where she put out you
know beauty is a terrible god to physics
and frank wrote back uh it worked out
pretty well for me
uh you know
garrett and i were kind of bemused by
that trolling uh of of sabine by frank
but of course it was meant in a friendly
way i'm sure but nevertheless uh the
question of you know kind of
survivorship bias came up and maybe
garrett you can just kind of reiterate
that you you've been you know lucky to
be privately supported to do these
things sabine even says it's a good
thing to have these things but she
doesn't go deep she claims to say it's
maybe not worth her time but uh tell me
something garrett first of all what when
you think about you know how do you
spend your time you know besides the
stuff outside of academia which we'll
talk about hopefully
uh you're the richard branson of of a
physicist of course
and that comes with with uh with with
problems as well as we talked about uh
previous hour but i want to ask you when
when you think about dividing your time
how much time do you spend thinking
about about geometric unity about the
wolfram physics project behind me and
this giant book in the back about this
new book uh this new theory of
everything by norbert schwertzer and max
tegmark's uh mathematically how much
time do you spend on it and if you say
none why is that why don't why wouldn't
you think about other people's theories
so first what how much time do you spend
on other theories
um
i think most theoretical physicists
spend enough time on others theories in
order to dismiss them
and so you would dismiss like wilfred's
theory so i'm not i'm not most
physicists i
spend for eric especially since we're uh
arch nemesis archangel msi and friends
um i've spent uh more than enough time
to dismiss it
um
for uh for wolf this is interesting
yeah we'll get your ex reaction a second
for wolfram
i've spent probably less than enough
time to dismiss it
and that's not because i don't respect
his work and the direction he's going
it's just that the direction he's chosen
to go in with cellular cellular automata
is so foreign to my area of expertise
that although i could dive into it and
disentangle it and try to make sense
instead what i do is i look at
all right well we have a rich model here
with some grand claims
what's the actual connection to known
physics and what i see as i see over and
over again is that the connection to
known physics is extremely tenuous if
there's much there at all
and
uh that's usually the easiest way to
dismiss
uh
work is how what what's the connection
to actual physics what's the connection
to the standard model
are you are you getting three
generations of fermions do you getting a
ctm matrix in some easy nice elegant way
how close is it
and by that metric you can almost
dismiss string theory i mean it's it's a
very it's a very high bar
um you can also dismiss my work i'm not
there yet but that's what i'm striving
for
but that's that's really what you want
to look for
and
but in terms of how i spend my time
i do spend a fair amount of time looking
at others papers
it's mostly papers centered around the
same area i'm working with or the area
i'm exploring
i'll
i'll be spending a lot more time
exploring papers on
mathematicians papers on generalized
lead groups
um uh colleagues papers uh working on
applying them to particle physics
uh i spend my that's how i spend my a
lot of my time i say i'd say probably
90 percent of my time is spent reading
others papers and only 10 working on my
own stuff so is it the case that you
have spent so much time
looking at geometric unity or sufficient
time that you've achieved the necessary
amount of time to dismiss geometric
unity or to maybe not not dismiss it but
not pay attention to it as much as say
you know something more close to e8 can
you can you expand upon what you meant
by that
um i all i was meant to be i was joking
that i have spent some time looking at
eric's work um more than i normally
would if we weren't uh so
uh disturbingly close
um
well let me let me follow up on that so
um when i when i look at these as an
outsider as an experimental let's ask
you have to ask me the question too
brian i'm about i'm about to get to that
so i want to i want to ask that question
but i want to ask it in a provocative
way because as
as garrett knows he started flying
lessons and uh one of the first things
you learn in flying is uh is to be very
careful about flying into instrument
conditions namely into clouds which can
obscure things but make you feel nice
and comfortable because everywhere you
look everything is nice homogeneous
isotropic and uniform like the inside of
a ping-pong ball but eric you know when
you look at it is is is there sort of a
um you know an out-group bias in that
there's so much group think in physics
as it is that now you've got these these
possible alternatives from wolfram from
you from uh tegmark etc and now you guys
are just going to fight but really the
the people who you are seeking are these
people occupying this behemoth cathedral
called string theory how do you decide
your time and how you spend it
well i think that
i think we have to clear something up
i don't take
uh stephen wolfram as having a theory of
everything or even a candidate i i take
him as having a program to search for
one i don't take max tegmark
as attempting a theory of everything i
view him in some sense as a mathematical
and physical philosopher looking to make
sure that when the theory is found it
will fit within the tegmarquian
perspective as some particular type of
multiverse or some uh type you know
because if if ultimately the description
is mathematical the claim will be the
teg mark was correct because he's now
somehow
laid claim to the mathematical universe
hypothesis which
i think almost every platonius has
considered so i don't quite understand
that as a theory of everything
i certainly don't see the loop quantum
gravity people as being serious about
particle phenomenology we know a lot
about the particles in the universe and
actually i believe
that the two that i really take some
semi-seriously are garrett's
and string theory
so
while garrett uh may be claiming that he
knows enough to dismiss mine certainly
that's not true no no yeah what i said
was that i've spent and i've spent more
than enough time with yours than needed
to dismiss it
okay did you
i forgot that garrett is not very
respectful he's not implying
implies i spent more than that amount of
time with it i don't know
fair point but the steel man garrett's
point and i do feel like there was a
misimpression
created by an artifact that happened
when he appeared on my show
i don't think that garrett is the best
person to extol the virtues of what he
is up to and i would say the following
you would have to give it to the string
theorists if your principal concern was
the idea that you wanted a
renormalizable theory of gravity however
far away they may be from that
that is their leading contribution you
can say a few things about what they
predict from black holes and then you
can also mumble something about how it's
useful in mathematics
clearly the string theorists have gotten
hold of a lot of advanced mathematics by
going to geometry and infinite
dimensions and uh in fact it's sort of
like finland finding estonia and saying
my god these people uh you know are
remarkable this is confirmation but in
fact finns and estonians are pretty much
the same people just separated by some
water
so i think that string theory is largely
an exclave of mathematics that is done
and performed in physics departments
garrett is doing something very
different if you asked what garrett's
principal contributions were and forgive
me garrett you can correct me given that
you're here
i love talking behind your back
um
garrett's principal
principal uh selling points
are the following he is the most
phenomenological
of any theory that is not geometric
unity that is his theory does the
following sorts of things first of all
it makes use of
a unique and canonical structure that
attempts to
tell us why this world and not others
because he begins with something called
e8 which is easily distinguishable in
the mathematical universe as being the
strangest of objects the platypus if you
will of mathematical symmetry
and second of all he incorporates
something that was found in the 1950s by
madame wu and yang and lee which is the
chirality of the universe because one of
the four forces seems to know it's left
from its right that is the weak force
um it is astounding that there is this
asymmetry and e8 contains some of this
asymmetry which we might call vile
fermions as opposed to dirac fermions
because e8 seems to know it's left from
its right so he gets that right then
there's a subtle property of e8 which is
actually disguised and so most
mathematicians and physicists don't know
about it it's manifest in something
called spin eight and that's the
principle of triality and so the idea
that triality is present and we have
three families is tantalizingly uh close
together so i would say that if you look
at what garrett oh furthermore garrett
is focused on something called cartan
connections
in which you co-mingle something called
an arismanian connection which is what
we have learned to use for the forces in
the standard model since the work of
simon's uh yang
singer and wu in
sony suny stoneybrook in the 1970s he
combines that with this sort of
einsteinian perspective
built on romanian geometry and the levi
chavetic connection and somehow the
levitic connection and uh this other
object the arismonian connection are
combined in something called a cartan
connection which is not really that
standard it fell out of favor in
mathematics
so
if you look at what garrett is doing and
and i believe even that garrett has now
strangely moved towards something called
super connections introduced by daniel
quillen and others in uh
jean
bismuth relationship yeah
so this in fact is some hope of
incorporating uh the difference in
quantization of forced particles and
matter particles
which is one of the original failings of
garrett's original first attempt at this
which is that he he too tightly
integrated matter and force in some
sense into the e8 structure so that the
matter that was present
in fact had to be looked at as force
so i think if you look at all of the
things that garrett is doing
well maybe lastly even another one the
fact that he's trying to drag a
canonical lagrangian or master of the
equations
from something like yang mills theory
is yet another um attempt at simplicity
and so you have him starting out with
something that's canonical that knows
it's left from its right intrinsically
that seems to have three encoded into it
when we see three copies of matter that
we're confused by that combines general
relativity and
the principal bundles that we've learned
a second form of geometry not due to
riemann due to arismond and in fact the
simplest of lagrangians that is really
why i've chosen garrett for my arch
nemesis because
i don't think anybody's actually said
this properly about garrett and so it's
important that garrett also be curated
because if you have to promote your own
theory
uh it's always suspicious that when a
book is mailed to you by the by its own
author then the idea is that a second
person hasn't said i see what that
person is saying
now the fact that garrett is hopelessly
and tragically wrong in my opinion is a
secondary concern
but the fact of the matter is that i
think i've chosen my nemesis well and he
may be more challenged in certain
aspects of quantizations and equations
but you have to admit that what he's
pursued um has been completely outside
of the norms and in fact
phenomenologically does far more than
any other theory to attempt to come
close to why we see the world that we do
and i just don't think that there's a
single other person including lee smolen
who can make the case as eloquently uh
for garrett uh who is not garrett
himself see garrett that you thought
this was going to be an intervention uh
but it's not don't worry um
that's coming soon that's coming soon uh
but i i want to ask both of you guys and
and how you look at each other because
you guys have remarkable lives i've i've
gotten to know eric uh extremely well
over the last year i feel blessed to do
that garrett i know you obviously by
reputation we've met a few times and
we're obviously you know very affiliated
with uc san diego and i enjoy that um
but i also know that you know time is
limited and i've always been curious uh
to get perspectives on people so eric is
an incredibly courageous brilliant
person who doesn't restrict himself to
just thinking about physics he goes on
talk shows like glenn beck and gets you
know half a million views because he is
just the exact person that is needed at
this troubling time in america to talk
to people on the right about what people
on the left um you know think about the
world and to reach consilience but not
just for its own sake garrett you're
known for starting institutions you're
known for having another uh set of of of
um influences on your time and on your
life do you guys ever look at each other
and say god
that guy just spent more time on physics
we'd really advance physics by a
tremendous amount or do you look at it
and say god the guy's not that serious
like if he was serious you know he'd be
he wouldn't be doing what that keating
guy does and just podcast all day he
would be doing stuff you know in his
wheelhouse in his lane what what do you
guys think about each other and and be
candid what do you feel eric that
garrett should spend more time you know
on the chalkboard and less time on the
surfboard eric uh you know garrett how
do you feel about what eric's involved
with should he is he denying you know
physics or math some sort of attention
that it really rightfully deserves let
me start with garrett first i know it's
uncomfortable but
let's go there
um
i think both of us have made extremely
unusual decisions in life and pushed
them
to a extraordinary and successful
degree
i think
eric has made choices early on that i
didn't and i have made choices that eric
didn't
and
i think we've both found uh perhaps
unreasonable amount of success in that
and i really respect eric a lot for his
decisions
uh what he's done in creating the portal
and
uh basically bootstrapping himself to
become one of the world's leading
intellectual voices
uh has been fantastic
and i think a lot of people especially
our mutual friendly smolin which is who
introduced me to eric
uh saw this potential early on and uh
and really it's been just inspiring to
see eric find such great success with
that
um
me i'm a little
i'm a little less social
i'm a little bit more of an introvert
even though i sort of founded an
institute here it's an institute for
introverts with like separate cabins
so people can stay away from each other
most social introvert in the world
there's lots of social distancing i'm
very comfortable with social distancing
um eric has decided to
uh
form himself a independent intellectual
online army
which is freaking fantastic i'm a little
terrified what he's gonna do with it
which direction that's going to go in
but it's been amazing and
uh
i would be extremely hypocritical to
look at someone else and say hey they
should really be spending more time on
physics is what they should be doing
um because uh i've been spending most of
my time for the past year actually
working on like surfing and kite surfing
and just trying to enjoy life in the
midst of a horrible pandemic
um it's been it's been hard for me to
concentrate on juggling equations
right and and for for eric he's got uh
he's you know he's he's grown a
wonderful family
um who i enjoy interacting with a great
deal when i visited
um and it's uh
that that's been a wonderful thing to to
see to see grow
um as well as uh
you know he went off uh to work in wall
street and financial management and he's
had a a wonderful career that way
and now working for peter kiel who is
also a a maverick
um that's that has been a great
partnership to see and uh he's grown
things in
that you know incredibly different
directions than i've gone in at the same
time i still know he's a skateboarder
down there
underneath
and i love seeing him you know i love
seeing him on an electric skateboard i
love seeing him paraglide i love seeing
him do fun stuff and if i influence them
in some positive way that's probably the
the most positive way i can implement
that all right enough of the
outside eric should should garrett spend
more time on the chalkboard
sure but that's
but there's a sort of a hidden problem
in the question which is
the people who send you books and who
send you um
you know equations written in red crayon
uh
you know declaring themselves the next
einstein
in general are not very self-conscious
they don't understand where they are and
one of the problems is that when you're
actually working independently if you're
doing it honestly
it's almost impossible not to succumb to
one mental problem or the other
either you come to believe that you are
the unique uh voice of god on earth
or you come to see yourself as you know
a failed loser outside of the system
scribbling things that mean nothing to
anyone and if you're smart you oscillate
between them in order to
you know keep your sanity so you do it
dialectically because it's very hard to
find a shelling point in the middle and
i think that you have to look at what
garrett does
as sustaining his ability to work
outside of the system the number of us
who are serious in working outside of
the system
is certainly less than one i can count
on one hand
and so i believe that in part
um just keeping your sanity while you
attempt this with everyone telling you
that you're an effing idiot uh or a
crazy person or an imposter or a grifter
or that you're thirsty all of these sort
of insults that are hurled by people who
don't actually live this life have you
been reading my mom's text messages to
me
well
i have a pack of hyenas that follows me
around the internet so you'll forgive me
the the point that i'm trying to get at
is that
if you think about what makes
what we do beautiful
it's
perhaps best exemplified in places like
cloudbreak and chopo and shipsterns and
in particular jaws
in
in maui these are waves they follow wave
equations and
the ability to interact
with let's say the differential geometry
of a ski slope
uh in the luxurious aspect of sitting in
maui and eating tropical fruit with a
white board is sustaining and so this is
what garrett's been on about with the
pacific science institute which i
heartily recommend people check out and
try to get behind
is that garrett has not only been
amusing himself to death but he's also
in fact attempting to share what he's
figured out
with the renegade scientific community
and i think that you have to view this
as admirable when billionaires have
stepped away from the private funding of
science when mark zuckerberg and yuri
milner can only come up with the
breakthrough prize for giving people who
are already in the system a little bit
more encouragement to keep doing what
they're doing that doesn't work i think
you have to look at what garrett's doing
as being an incredibly constructive
attempt to take a small amount of money
that he's turned into a larger amount of
money through
i would say dumb luck but he would call
it investing
um
and that he effectively is trying to
found something like xerox park or uh
you know tuxedo park or any of these
great private endeavors in order to keep
physics alive which it's clearly in
danger of dying so i think i think that
garrett needs more encouragement
and if he was more encouraged he would
spend more time in physics but it's
almost impossible to spend your time
doing this
when it appears that what's really going
on is that your mind is unraveling that
you think that there's something
peculiar about you that will allow you
to succeed where everyone else has
collectively failed and i think
garrett's doing a marvelous job of
staying in the game the fact that he
wastes most of his time on other
pursuits it may not be a waste at all it
may simply be you know a way of saving
your sanity now we just had a
conversation with
garrett that i asked the same question i
asked of you
a long time ago but i'll ask it again
and maybe garrett can reiterate his
opinions afterwards do we need a theory
of everything so
people go on and on about these
different theories of everything because
we don't believe that in the current
understanding of the laws of physics
that gravity is commensurate compatible
and fits into
a quantization scheme we're in the
wave-like properties and graviton-like
properties of a uh truly quantum theory
of gravity would take place however i
always point out and you guys have
pointed out you know most of the
scenarios where people talk about as
kamran baffa did on my show as juan
maldosena did on my show they're talking
about gravity
in anti-descender space in five
dimensional uh you know space times and
you're talking about an abstraction that
is not gravity i'm talking about
abstractions that is not gravity number
one and two they are solving you know
they're answering a question that i
don't believe anybody has fully asked
from the experimental perspective i'll
explain what that means i said this to
garrett so garrett bear with me but john
preschool was on the show last week and
i said john you know we say we need a
quantum theory of gravity because we
don't understand uh gravity at the
center of a singularity or in the
beginning of the universe if indeed it
had a big bang uh singularity at its
origin uh but what if you know we just
the universe is not described by a
single big bang it's more described as
roger penrose's conformal cyclic
cosmology or paul steinhardt and neil
turrock's ecpirotic or bouncing
classical cosmologies these have no
singularities whatsoever they are not
manifest at all so that's one motivation
50 percent of the motivation of quantum
gravity destroyed nuked wrecked uh but
uh and similarly we don't believe there
are any such thing as naked
singularities where we could probe a
singularity uh visible and i said john
presque isle you are the richard p
feynman professor of physics at
california institute of technology a
small technical college in uh in los
angeles county i said feynman said
i don't care how beautiful your
equations are if it doesn't agree with
experiment it's wrong
now i ask you guys uh we can't ever hope
to access these two different domains
which are the only two domains to my
knowledge uh that that quantum
gravitational effects are manifest why
why would you guys spend so much time on
this field where it may not even be
necessary to unify gravity with quantum
mechanics or is there a bigger project
at work
yeah would you mind if i took that one
first and then you back clean up
okay first of all um let's dispense with
this issue of uh
the task of this generation being to
quantize gravity this is a very
particularly quantum field theoretic
perspective where the children of boar
have always been pissed off that
einstein did so much better in some
sense on his side of the ledger that he
cleaned things up so that his children
were impoverished whereas bohr failed to
clean things up so his children have had
a much richer world to mine okay
so the idea of getting einstein to
submit to bohr
has been a long-held dream of a subset
of the community
if you think about it differently you
could ask the question of instead of why
do we have to quantize einstein's
geometry why not geometrize bohr's
quantum which is exactly what actually
happened so part of the problem is is
that when you get your information and
your news updates from ed whitton
uh or the institute for advanced study
which has gone on gone in heavily with
string theory
perhaps notwithstanding
what you start to realize is that you've
been sold one particular story about
physics and it's time to destroy the
dominance of that narrative in favor of
other narratives let's talk about the
feynman quote feynman i believe it was
at cornell when he made this comment
that if your theory doesn't agree with
experiment it's wrong
no
not right your instinct the
instantiation of your theory is wrong
but this is the point of derock's 1963
article in scientific american where he
talks about schrodinger
not incorporating spin and failing to
get agreement with experiment the theory
was basically correct
but in fact the instantiation was wrong
this is why the scientific method
doesn't get you out of as much when you
apply it naively nor does popper so
people are not only in love with papa
and the scientific method they're in
love with very simplistic versions of
that with the idea that you can always
go home and the rationality
and the scientific method is enough to
clean up physics now you're copy editing
physics that's not where the real magic
happens the real magic happens in a tiny
number of places and sabine is generally
by the way correct that beauty tends to
lead almost all physicists onto the
rocks and destroys their career and
makes sure that they're not very
productive the only problem with her
theory is is that it doesn't work for
the far right tale of physics where it
succeeds beautifully and by the way i
don't believe that wilcheck's work is
beautiful in the way that
let's say garrett's work
is beautiful
maybe the garrett's work is wrong but
his ideas are definitely beautiful the
way in which will check's work is
beautiful has to do with particular
properties of let's say qcd at an
analytic level
and
i think there are even different forms
of beauty unfortunately sabine has
decided that she doesn't want to target
string theory directly and so she's
decided that she's going to be
tilting at the proxy of beauty because
beauty is invoked by string theorists in
an attempt to shut everybody else up
well she's quite correct that the
attempt to shut everybody else up about
the cosmic failure of string theory to
deliver on its promises
is in fact a huge danger and may
threaten the destruction of the
theoretical physics community which we
need for a variety of reasons because it
is our most accomplished intellectual
community ever full stop
then
you have this problem about
feynman now feynman in many ways uh
exemplifies for many people
um various things and his aphorisms
which i don't think he would have taken
as seriously as his
followers uh seem to are wielded as
weapons if you can't explain it to your
grandmother then you don't understand it
i do not
you know that which i cannot create i do
not understand blah blah blah
well okay but then again if you look at
the conversation between feynman and
dirac it's very clear that feynman
really never had a fundamental law of
physics and the number of people who've
done that have been
extremely few in number it's a very
different club and all of them appear to
subscribe to the concept of beauty which
is what i view garrett for example is
pursuing now
garrett is not going on to the rocks
his theory may be wrong but it's
certainly something that needed to be
explored it's a canonical theory and i
don't mean garrett any disrespect but
when i met him
at a conference that i think sabine
actually hosted uh with lee smolin
i had actually looked at ea myself for
exactly the reasons that garrett has now
i think i've detailed a number of things
that garrett did that i didn't do with
that theory i think it's the second most
interesting and promising idea i don't
think it works
but it needed to be explored and it
needed to have an actual physicist
exploring it and i'm very very happy and
you know if my stuff the only reason i
want garrett to be wrong is that i want
me to be right if i turn out to be wrong
i would like nothing better than for
garrett to be vindicated in what he in
what it is that he's doing that's the
real basis of this rivalry right
but the issue is that
i think that we've got all of these
incredibly simplistic ideas the most
interesting thing that's happened is is
that all of the people who've been
telling you that they know how science
works it's all about peer review that
it's all about exp agreement with
experiment that
you have to be able to explain it to
your mother that there doesn't need to
be a theory of everything that beauty is
a problem none of these people have
succeeded
okay
so
at some point when you haven't really
succeeded in pushing things forward in
50 years almost in certain terms
you have to say maybe all of the crap
that we say
is wrong there's this marvelous scene
i'll close with this
in no country for old men where anton
chaguer
asked the character played by woody
harrelson i've forgotten his name
unfortunately
was it carter can't remember he says if
the path
you took led you to this what of what
use was that path
and that's exactly right with all of
these things that we quote popper or
agreement with experiment scientific
method if everything has stalled you out
for 50 years why is it that you're not
listening to people who actually have
new ideas ask yourself that
i think one might say you know that
that people are maybe overwhelmed with
popper i mean i i use this example with
martin reece when he was on the show uh
you know if you look at the pinkening
and the reddening of the sunset uh as
the sun goes down to the horizon at uh
every night
that uh you would be led most naturally
to believe that uh the round earth has
been falsified because it's much more
consistent with the flat earth uh that
the uh such a behavior should take place
in an atmospheric slab approximation so
i wonder if people aren't overwhelmed uh
by popper and overwhelmed by this is the
counter that someone like lenny suskin
gave on the show that people are
obsessed with it and i can give another
example so uh astronaut astrology which
i'm often confused for you know when i'm
not confused for being a cosmetologist
because of my awesome weinstein-like
coif uh i am usually cons confused with
being an astrologer and i usually say
yeah um oh you're a pisces that's very
interesting that lump on your butt is
cancerous go check it out but seriously
i you know astrology has been falsified
uh by numerous double-blind tests
including one in nature magazine does
that mean it's science because popper
says it's not science unless it's
falsifiable and obviously that's uh
meant to be a supplement an augmentation
but garrett i wonder what would it take
to get you in this maybe maybe it is an
intervention i'm sorry garrett sorry to
spring this on you what would it take
for you to put all your chips all your
apple stock all your bitcoin into
uh geometric unity you know for example
at what point would it rise you say you
you've studied it enough and your tongue
and cheek say you know it's you know
enough to be wrong but not to be right i
don't know but but tell me what would it
take for you to pursue because at the
end of the day we're here on this blue
marble for you know 120 years hopefully
but probably you know less in some cases
so tell me what would it take for you to
pursue you know another theory wolfram
maybe that's not even make it personal
but you know with eric but what it takes
to make it personal all right so we have
two of us on this show all right let's
go for it toe to toe oh fear of it eric
has taken a uh
using a lot of the same tools that i've
been playing with he's built up a very
interesting theory in a very different
way
so he has started with a 14-dimensional
manifold that incorporates the metric
and then sort of gauge the metric
in a way that accommodates its
uh
interaction with fermions in a in a way
that is
very different than any and then how
gravity is usually introduced to
interact with the fermions
so right off the bat he's starting with
a
kind of outlandish structure that
nevertheless
matches up well
with known physics from a very different
approach
which is the sort of thing that
absolutely i feel in the same way should
be explored and i'm glad he's exploring
it
because it's not the way that i would uh
approach things
i wouldn't i wouldn't start out by
gauging the metric i would gauge the
frame which is equivalent to the metric
but is more natural for use with
fermions but but eric chose to start
with the metric and i think that's a
very valuable way to
to look at things and to proceed
um for me to jump on board within going
and swallowing and looking more into
geometric unity than i have
um i'd really like to see
him get something like the c cam matrix
out
with the with mixing angles appearing in
some natural reasonable way
um that's a high bar
as far as i know nobody can do this in a
natural looking way i can't do it
um
others haven't been able to do it
strength theory can't do it so you want
to just briefly say what the ckm matrix
is for the kids at home right so the ckm
metrics it basically tells you
um that for your three generations of
matter particles
right when you have like your you have
your up and your down quarks
in your in your first generation
and your uh your strange and your charm
quarks and your second generation and
your your
bottom and your top quark in the in the
third generation
uh what are the masses of these things
well they don't have distinct masses
if they're identified as
as unique particles with respect to the
forces
so instead their masses are mixed
between those three generations
and there's a mixing matrix that allows
them that describes uh how their masses
are assigned between them and how they
can oscillate between them
and we also now have a a similar matrix
called the pmns matrix after the the
first theorist to write about it
for neutrinos and electrons
and getting these matrices out of a
theory is necessary for matching up with
known physics and is necessary for and
this is where probably the
the new predictions will come from any
successful unified theory is with these
the parameters in these two matrices and
how they relate
and it's very difficult to build your
structure up
uh or break it down from existing
symmetry going the other direction
and get something like these matrices
and their mixing angles out in in a nice
way
and it's a very high bar
but if that were to happen
for a geometrically based theory in a
natural way that didn't sneak them in by
hand somehow that that would immediately
command my attention and i would swap
all my investment into looking at that
and i'd also see if it related to my
stuff because that's what theirs do
there's also always tried to relate new
stuff to theirs
but uh that would immediately command a
whole lot of attention and like i said
it's a high bar
and i think garrett is also uh if i
i feel comfortable putting words into
his mouth since he can take them out
given that he's here
i think that garrett is using the ckm
matrix as but one of many examples in
other words there are things that are
concrete
that show that there is a new idea
present and what is particularly bizarre
is when people say that they have a
theory of everything and there is no new
idea that you can hear coming out of
their mouths that's right so
a different way of saying the ckma keep
in mind that i'm an imposter rather than
a physicist so i feel uncomfortable
saying anything to the to the folks at
home but you have a situation whereby
the algebraically natural object
which might be called a flavor
eigenstate let's say and the um
observed object the mathematically
massive object in the theory are not
necessarily exactly lining up
and
one of the problems is that we don't
really
know how to generate mass except for
this as if mass that we call the higgs
mechanism
so
in fact it's not even real mass the way
we thought we were going to find mass it
has to do with another object called the
yukawa coupling
whereby this higgs field is lured away
from its zero value which would have all
of us zipping around at the speed of
light to some finite value called a vev
and then the idea is that it's this vev
that requires explanation the reason i
bring this up is that the old
reductionist hopes that you would find
the ckm matrix and other things of that
nature as fundamental values
has been shown in some sense to be
a very naive hope that there's some
things that are encoded into the
equations of physics and there are other
things that are encoded into the
particular region and time of space that
we find ourselves in in the happenstance
so you're never sure if you have a
number hard coded into the theory as to
whether or not that number exists as a
scalar
thinking of it in computer science terms
how do you cast that isn't it is it an
integer a ratio of integers is it is it
a float or is it a field and one of the
problems is that we have these two
things the cosmological constant in the
higgs field and maybe the inflaton maybe
three things that may in some sense be
disguised as real numbers but it may in
fact vary the way you wouldn't say
what's the temperature on earth uh today
you would say well what's the field of
temperatures distributed over the earth
so in our region you might say it's 70
76 degrees
but fahrenheit but but you might
be fooled into thinking that it's 76
degrees everywhere because you're just
too focused on your own navel gazing so
if the ckm matrix in fact is encoded
field theoretically as a bunch of
numbers
um that happen to be relatively constant
at our particular moment in space and
time
you know
that's one thing
we don't know fundamentally what it
should be we don't know where the yukawa
couplings or the mexican hat potential
come from all of these gadgets that feel
artificial
may in fact be accidents of an anthropic
principle that they happen to be at this
values for us to observe them so one of
the problems that's developed of late in
theoretical physics is how do you split
up the things that are fundamental to
the equations and the lagrangian which
governs the equations and how many of
these are emergent accidents having to
do either with anthropics or the the
good fortune just to be
alive at this time and in this place
that said i believe that garrett will be
working on geometric unity by the end of
this year
that was a bold bold statement well uh
first of all i want to take a little
brief pause when that haymaker was
landed let's take a quick break to uh
ask people to stretch your fingers do
not get carpal tunnel syndrome do not
succumb to carpal tunnel syndrome press
the like button subscribe to the into
the impossible podcast so i can get
great guests like this i'm going to have
car a little ravelli on next week i'm
going to have avi loeb on in the next
week i've got a short track to maybe get
on jared
i don't know how to pronounce it uh he
and i have been communicating and many
many other great episodes it would be
great to have it hoofed on this channel
by the way garrett can we do something
that brian cannot do and just can you
say what you think the quality of
brian's guests other than the crazy
people working outside of the system has
been
i i went through his guest list and i
was uh more than enough more than
impressed enough to come and be a guest
myself
that's right and and
that was enough
thank you eric and you were i said on
twitter recently you're one of my main
role models as is sabine and lex
friedman and all those great uh
podcasters out there but uh garrett
didn't realize i want to say a little
bit more brian go ahead you can't say
this all right
willingness to go outside of the system
and your ability to get the top people
in the system
is unparalleled anywhere else uh you
know lex friedman is doing something
like that but you're actually doing it
from inside
uh
the system and i don't know of a single
other person who is uh maybe maybe max
tegmark would be the other person
through fqxi and his and anthony anthony
aguirre is co-founder of fqxi but so far
as i know there are really
two or three
people who are risking their reputations
to talk to people from outside of the
system and able to bring people into the
system i would say perimeter fqxi and
the into the impossible podcast and it
needs to be said that brian is taking a
huge risk talking to people like us and
taking it seriously and that he's
managing to do it with so much integrity
that he's still able to get you the top
people and uh i just think it's an
amazingly courageous thing to do from
the position of a chaired professorship
well thank you very much and that will
do a long uh good bit of help for me
when i have people on uh like deepak
chopra who is also on the show in the
following weeks and i do get a lot of
criticism how can i have this crackpot
on and and actually you know one of the
most most delightful things about this
podcast is that i get to talk to people
i want to talk to people that excite and
interest the mind and that satisfy the
intellectual curiosity of this podcast
is to create the university i wish i
went to and although garrett did go to
this university called uc san diego the
best in my opinion in the known
multiverse um and he doesn't know that
actually alumni relations has a request
for his donation of apple stock later in
the podcast but
we won't get into that uh now i do
appreciate that eric it is it's not so
it's not as courageous as the things
that you guys are doing but it is
interesting to me to keep my brain going
and talk to the people that i wanted to
talk to ever since i was a kid people at
the forefront that have intellectual
curiosity and have uh and have courage
that's an extremely rare trait so yes
please help me uh spread the message
about the podcast subscribe to my
mailing list briankeating.com i'm
sending out life lessons from jim simons
and from michael saylor and from eric
weinstein and i'm going to write up some
life lessons i learned from garrett
lisey as well let's get back to this uh
i often hear as i did uh when i talked
to stephen wolfram by himself and then
eric and uh stephen got together for a
live debate over the summer as well but
i said which of you guys really thinks
that this theory of everything is doing
a disservice because it's actually in my
opinion what's what steven has is not
going to come up with the aharan of
boehm effect or maybe it will but maybe
it won't come up with with uh bell's
inequality in other words it's not
really a theory of everything it might
be a unified theory or something like
that so garrett let me ask you is is you
know e8 is exceptional uh theory that
you've developed is that really going to
come up with things like the double slit
experiment is it going to come up with
strange spooky action in that distance
or is it is it not and i'm saying this
merely but it's not pejorative in any
sense is it restricted to unification
via mathematical structures in this
representation theory
fashion
um
the short answer is no
because e8 does not inherently contain a
geometric description of quantum physics
which is something that eric said he was
uh
that ultimately we were going to need to
go for so if you really want a unified
theory
and uh not be faking it
you also need a description of quantum
physics in a natural way that includes
the things you you described
so that's what i'm working on next
so i'm next working on structures such
as generalized lead groups that
inherently contain descriptions of
quantum physics that would start to be
able to give you exactly those things
that you described
and eric would it emerge from you and i
have talked about this but for the
record let's say it in front of uh
garrett what where where in lies things
like the uh spooky action at a distance
like bells and equal does that lie
within the geometric unity purview
i don't even understand garrett's
response and his own theory so let's
first of all criticize garrett before we
put me in hot water all right go for it
all right
the thing about
i don't think garrett is actually
accurate uh
one of the really important things about
what happened in the 1970s where we
actually made progress but we pretend
that we didn't make progress in the
structure of mathematics because we're
embarrassed where the progress happened
it happened around the mathematics of
field theory rather than in the
specifics of the field theory that
seemed to describe our world
in fact if garrett has a lagrangian
which he does
and that lagrangian
is applied to the fields which it is
garrett will find that he will have
something called a phase space he'll
have a configuration space he will have
a phase space the phase space will
inherit a structure called a symplectic
form
that symplectic form will become the
curvature of a differential operator on
something called a line bundle
and that line bundle
is a something like the x y plane where
you can look at functions
and those functions will become the
quantum states of a quantum field theory
so i think that what garrett just said
even whereas planck's constant come in
there i mean you you don't you don't
have quantum mechanics you have to add
it's something up to add it doesn't come
out naturally from that i don't agree
with this necessarily i believe the
geometric quantization
there are some things that we say about
quantum theory that i have not been
convinced of one is that it's an art
rather than a functor
but i think the geometric quantization
goes a long way towards saying
that just as
vinters the vintners claim that wine is
what happens when you stop grape juice
from becoming
vinegar
well in some sense classical field
theory is what happens when you stop
a mechanics from quantizing itself and i
think the garrett's theory is entirely
capable of quantizing itself in a
geometric quantization
format simply by virtue of the fact that
uh
through a legendre transformation he'll
get from a lagrangian to a hamiltonian
picture the hamiltonian picture will
turn out to be affiliated with a line
bundle and then when the spooky action
at a distance uh will come up in the
multi-particle theory as his theory
quantizes itself and i don't understand
his pessimism that's not his problem i
he's got bigger he's got bigger
himself i i think of quantum mechanics
as a as kind of bringing in a whole
bunch of structural elements
that either have to appear by hand or i
guess
i can see
a few pages out of woodhouse and i think
that you'll find you're in far better
shape if you can just get your stuff in
order
happy to have a look i still think of
quantum mechanics as a
uh a structure that most
physicists would uh
bring in as a toolkit to use with other
things rather than something that
emerges naturally from a from a
geometric system we'll see from a little
bit of your point of view how you'd see
it that way yeah i'm more sanguine that
because garrett has
hugged the shore of geometry
uh he will be richly rewarded if he can
ever get his stuff to really work
well let me ask some questions from the
audience uh because there's uh over
almost yeah there's 1100 people watching
live thank you we treasure each and
every one of you
and uh i want to ask a question about
the impact of of of string theory why is
it so
worthy of uh at least somewhat muted
derision perhaps by
basically everyone who's got an
alternative grand unified or super
unified theory why why is it uh make the
steel man case for string theory first
eric and then uh and then i'd like to
hear uh from uh from garrett although we
did discuss that so we'll maybe ask
an alternate question of garrett so as
not to repeat himself but ask you
eric what's the case for string theory
uh even if not to devote uh even if we
ignore the amount of resources that have
been devoted to it let's just take the
case of string theory qua string theory
what
what what's good about it
well i mean first of all there's a
certain amount of naturality at the
beginning of it which is why
just generalize hard little balls which
aren't exactly right why not start from
things that are more interesting than
hard little balls
like tiny little pieces of string and
circles vibrating in some other space
i think that you then you ask the
question about why did gravity not
succumb to the same
tools that worked well for what we would
call spin one half
matter and spin one forces other than
gravity and and now for the higgs field
so we just spin zero now there are two
other cases there's spin three halves
and spin two before you crap out of this
game
in which everything in the theory has to
come with uh with some fraction between
zero and two
in that situation uh there's a puzzle as
to why gravity doesn't easily submit to
this
quantum imperialism and
the hope was that if you found any
circumstance in which the gravity
appeared to behave better
then
in that framework then that would have
to be right and that was supplemented
in the early 1980s by some very bizarre
discoveries where there were some very
narrow
constraints called an anomaly
cancellation which appeared to pick out
a tiny number of candidates and so
what was tantalizing was that uh if
somebody had actually found a way to
circumvent the problems with quantizing
gravity and
there were a tiny number of coincidences
that were necessary clearly uh you know
the good lord hashem was urging us on a
path to find these things and you could
do it through process of elimination at
that point string theory turned
murderous and the murderousness is
really the problem it's not
string theory per se that's the problem
it was the behavior patterns of the
physicists who became so drunk on power
and so completely thoroughly obnoxious
and i want to talk about obnoxious above
the obnoxious level that physicists are
usually at
physics is a very physics a very
dangerous and difficult subject and
because it is the most accomplished of
communities
arrogance has been a fundamental aspect
of doing theoretical physics just as
humility has been
an important aspect and those two things
are co-mingled
when physics had been failing for a
relatively brief period of time about 10
years and string theory was found to
have this anomaly cancellation the
string theory community went into some
level of obnoxiousness that has never
before been seen in physics they became
completely intolerable they also started
doing things like saying
uh everything is string theory just sort
of like bitcoin maximalists where the
bitcoin solves everything i'm having a
problem with my children don't worry
bitcoin solves that uh if you find
anything that isn't string theory don't
worry we'll just call it string theory
everything that you can do we will write
a paper called blank whatever you did
plus its stringy origins
it is that complete uh intellectual
dishonesty and the failure of the string
theorists who embraced it to face it and
the fact that it's concentrated in the
baby boom generation as a means of
deferring the ultimate tango with
reality
where they can keep pumping out papers
and saying look this is a bit of the
21st century that fell into the 20th
century
fell into the 20th century
no it's not um the fact of the matter is
it's a bit of the 20th century that's
still hanging around in the 21st century
they refuse to ship a product for
different reasons
than other people who are struggling
with it and more neurons have been spent
exploring this theory and failing to
find a way to connect it to anything
other than mathematical reality so on
the one hand
it's been incredibly interesting because
it backfired on the physics community
the people who thought that they would
quantize einstein's geometry in fact got
it exactly wrong what they did is that
they geometrized the quantum and so
people who who
earned as geometers doing infinite
dimensional differential geometry and
the like spent as string theorists they
would accomplish things in mathematics
and then they would say
this is exactly why string theory is
correct this is a bit what milton
friedman did when he earned as an
economist and he spent uh as a
polemicist telling people what they had
to do for their social society very
often people earn in one place and spend
somewhere else so in part the problem
that we've had is that we have these
people who we absolutely love who have
been doing amazing work but it's not the
work that they claim that they're doing
they've been
advancing the mathematics of quantum
field theory they've been exploring
extensions of quantum field theory they
are not when they say that we're doing
something in gravity usually it's not
about gravity when they say that they're
talking about particles they're not
talking about particles as i've joked
many string theorists i don't think
could find the men's room at cern
if their life depended on it they are
not in contact with the physical world
they forget things
you know like the gelman nishijima
formula and things that you know garrett
probably still cares about i think that
the the serious problem is is that
there's no one in a position to tell
some of the world's most brilliant
people that there's an aspect of q anon
in physics this is the cargo cult
science that firemen warned us about and
the fact is we can't necessarily just go
towards brian's preferred
answer about depending upon experiment
and we can't trust the people who've
claimed beauty
the way sabine has been going after the
string theorists and the fact is that
the string theory community has not been
economically powerful because we have
economically undermined the physics
community as with every other academic
science community in order to have this
work you have to go back to the
political economy
of physics
the political economy of physics demands
that the middle finger be accessible to
every generation so that we don't wait
for funeral by funeral what's happening
now is that the baby boomers are
eventually going to age out the key
dividing line is 1951. frank wilcheck
who you've just had on your show was the
last person in some sense to make
contact with the standard model ed
whitton born in the same year
a little bit later in the year is a guy
who could not possibly have been denied
a nobel prize at this age in any other
time period this guy is one of the most
brilliant people and i hope to god brian
that you have him on your show despite
my frustrations with him it has been an
honor to live in the same era as edwin
well he says there's only room for one
ew on the into the impossible podcast
[Laughter]
and my response to that joke is you
the point is is that ed whitton
is one of the most important minds alive
and he is he has earned
uh a tremendous amount of respect
based on what he's done for geometry but
more importantly the mathematics of
field theory to show the quantum field
theory rather than a grab bag of strange
things that happen to work
is a canonical and necessary
mathematical structure but what he has
not done is to show us that string
theory is the likely winner and the key
problem is is that we have got to have
open debates in the community where the
people in the holy of holies the
institute for advanced study are
actually on the same stage with people
who can competently disagree with them
for the same reasons that it is
important that many of us who do not
support what's going on with the
democratic party of the united states uh
because we don't think that it any
longer represents a real and workable
left and that we think that it has gone
down an incredibly dangerous path have
to be allowed in the same programs as
people like brian williamson uh brian
williams rather or don lemon because
what we have is an illusion and the
illusion of string theory is what's
causing the bitterness it's not the
string theory and it's not even the work
that the string theorist has done it is
the murderous intent by which they have
stunted other communities that have
sought to challenge them as and say you
know what you haven't gotten as far as
you claim and you are not correct that
other avenues shouldn't be pursued so
that you can gobble up the resources
yeah when i when i had the conversation
i did with shelly glashow we'll get to
in a minute um you know basically i said
you know he's a leader and i actually
communicated this with with ed whitton
the first time i'm not so easy to get uh
to dispose of edwin don't worry i'll be
back for more uh requests to have you on
the into the impossible podcast but i
also said to nima akane ahmed who is
going to come on the podcast i've got a
lot of uh uh institute adjacency to ed
i'm hopeful that edward will come on the
podcast but i said to nima he's a leader
and i started to think what is a leader
and there was a wonderful uh statement
made by the lebovacher rebbe who garrett
lisi i'm sure knows all about uh being a
good habadnik that garrett no no garrett
you don't know any of these words
probably but there's
there's a form of judy like garrett you
know you've done most of the hard work
you had the circumcision you're fine the
rest is all downhill but the laboratory
rebbe was a great great leader and he
said
good leaders good leaders to eric's
point create many followers great
leaders create many leaders and i see
that as kind of happening at least
to not nearly to the same extent in
theoretical physics as it is in my field
of experimental physics i know so many
talented experimentalists that are far
better than me more creative harder
working more imaginative the future of
experimental physics i think is
extremely bright despite what certain
naysayers will say however i think there
is this reluctance to relinquish the
stage the to enter and bow out as eric
is alluding to from some of the boomers
and and so forth and i'm getting up
there myself but but nevertheless in the
theoretical community and i wonder your
reaction to that this following
statement uh for an experimentalist it's
ironic because i don't believe that
experimentalists do their best work by
the time they're 30 the way it's often
rumored to be true for mathematicians uh
and maybe theoretical physicists in fact
experimental physicists get better with
age
because we get better and better at
knowing what experimental techniques
work which applications based on
accumulated shared wisdom etc take place
so actually the opposite takes place
your easier job of getting into
experimental physics after having you
know some exposure to it than maybe
theoretical physics although you guys
might debate that but i want to talk
about leadership in the field you guys
are both known for making uh prolific
amounts of money and sums of money uh
that uh are from your bets from your
bets with nobel laureates in fact and i
want to talk about the two bets that are
most prominent in my mind garrett really
got paid i got a dollar off of shelley
glacier after 27 years to garrett i know
well that's right so garrett uh got a
subscription to to play girl no no i
don't know what he got but
something else but uh but i want to ask
you guys so let me first say this the
public bet that garrett made with frank
wilcheck was that super particles would
not be detected by the 8th of january
8th of july 2015. he gave him a one-year
extension for more data collection frank
wilcheck conceded the super particle bet
to lisey in 2016. i had frank on the
show recently i had on shelly glashow on
the show recently we're talking about
the failure of uh of super symmetry to
so in this case why isn't it true that
that these nobel laureates are taking
the advice of their fellow laureate uh
richard feynman in other words we know
that it doesn't agree with with
experiment so why is this still
so persistent is it an illusion let me
ask garrett why do you think these
things like frank still believes that
super symmetry has a chance for success
even despite his pecuniary dilemma that
he is and now courtesy of you actually
how could you take his whole salary i
mean that
he only gets five salaries from the five
different institutions that have hired
him it didn't even put a debt in it but
it did have four digits so i was happy
to receive it for the pacific sciences
so um
uh and i was very and he was a wonderful
person yesterday for honoring that bet
and so lovely for not welching on it
um
i do have i think a good perspective on
this
um when i first
built up this you know the algebraic
structure of the standard model in
gravity into one algebraic hole and just
saw how perfectly it fit into e8
i was like there's got to be something
here there's no way this is coincidence
just algebraically it's just would be an
outlandish thing if this just was a
coincidence too beautiful to be wrong
yeah exactly it's too beautiful to be
wrong
um and i think
uh frank wolfcheck experienced i'm just
um you know guessing here but i think he
experienced something very similar
when he did his calculation
with a uh s so10 granulified model
extended with supersymmetry
and saw that the coupling constants the
way they run at higher energies and if
you do it just with so10 they just miss
each other
but if you do it with super symmetry
those coupling constants when they run
they converge much more closely
and when he saw that i think he had the
same realization that this has to be
true this is too beautiful to be wrong
super simple this super symmetry
combined with this granule theory with
the with the coupling constants merging
to one value at high energy that's cute
if you're wrong and i think he's hung on
to that ever since
um what he doesn't may not have uh
respected is that you know the super
particles haven't shown up
um when you look more closely at the
convergence when you go to higher loops
in the renormalization calculation these
coupling constants don't merge
uh
perfectly with supersymmetry added so
it's not as great of a coincidence as he
first appreciated
and he just you know
he had a very personal experience that
caused him to have these beliefs i think
this is very similar to people i mean i
mean do not mean this an insulting way
but i think many people can be misled
this way if they have personal
experiences that lead them to believe
weird things that aren't true i think
people believe in god
i think people believe in astrology for
this reason it's like oh i bet this
person they're this sign they match all
the things in the sign there must be
something to it it's like because of
personal experience we tend to draw uh
unrealistic models eric does that apply
to you
it does i think that because i had this
experience of seeing the standard model
fit into e8 perfectly the first time
with this hint of triality for the three
generations uh i think that gave me
unusual confidence that something along
these lines had to be true i think what
gary is saying is profound here this is
really an important point if you take
the anomaly cancellation if you take the
triality together with the
uh
chirality of e8 for garrett if you take
the running coupling constant convergent
for frank wilcek and probably also
cancellations in the perturbation theory
of supersymmetric theories when the
supersymmetry isn't you know too too far
off or badly broken in order to say why
it isn't here already
um
the
another one would be the uh convergence
inside of spin 10
uh that garrett is referring to of
georgia and glashow and there's another
version due to petite and salam
all of these things have been extremely
tantalizing
and the problem is that everything
smells like we're almost finished if not
with the whole story certainly this
chapter of the story
and i believe that that is driving many
people crazy which is really the steel
manning of sabina's point
as to why uh this is happening now
garrett can i just ask and sort of take
brian's role here for one second
why did you become confident enough to
bet against frank wilceck
that
clearly i know you have no penchant for
losing money
and you put yourself in a very
vulnerable position what gave you the
confidence that super partners would not
be found
all right
and you know what's coming next right
which is the fact that you're using
super connections so that you are
starting to move a little bit in the
direction of super symmetry
is moving into your pocket stuff that is
uh that that i'm not uh
that i'm aware of in my own work
um but for super symmetry and super
particles specifically
um
it was a work
that i read uh from a paper in the 90s
uh i think by peskin
and that work
just took the last stone
out of the structure that was holding up
evidence for supersymmetry
there are arguments for
super symmetry
and that stone was that with
supersymmetry
um you get uh
uh
a more successful renormalization for
the higgs field
okay that you get that you can you can
balance things better with super
symmetry that super particles perform
this role
where you can
get renormalization to work out better
and more successfully in a more natural
way
and then this has been a one of several
arguments for super symmetry
uh that's been used to support it
theoretically and what i found in this
paper by peskin i think it was from 97
or something
was that if you just have more higgs
degrees of freedom you can get the same
sort of con same sort of balancing of in
renormalization
and
that's like wow that's right this
argument really just comes down to one
parameter
to get something to match up and if you
can just wiggle some other parameter you
can get the same sort of balancing and
get everything to work out so you don't
need supersymmetry you don't need this
whole zoo of super particles and at that
point the
uh
the chain of logic required
to support a belief of in super symmetry
just totally fell apart it's like
there's there's just no evidence for
this mathematically from a mathematical
perspective i look at it it's like super
symmetry isn't even that pretty
mathematically mathematicians tend not
to deal with it because it's just kind
of not really
mathematically elegant
and
uh with so little evidence for it it
just seemed like there was a extreme
unusual amount of confidence
um in super symmetry among physicists
among high energy theorists
and i had an opportunity at a conference
to take advantage of frank wilczyk and
his generosity and putting him on the
spot during during a talk he was giving
and and make this bet and he took it
because he i know he had an unusual
amount of confidence in the symmetry and
uh and and he uh humored me in taking
this bet
well this is fireman's description of
jimmy the greek in vegas making money
off people that wanted to bet that they
could beat jimmy the greek and that you
hubris is the source of profit but
garrett uh in a weird way even though
you've won frank's money by forcing him
into a uh a compromised position where
he has to support his uh unnatural
exuberance exuberant
is frank not in some sense winning this
bet as i watch super symmetry start to
invade your e8 program
um
frank wilcheck has won all sorts of ways
and he's a great guy and i think
deserves it he deserves everything he's
won
um
uh i'm not religious about anything
if it turns out supersymmetry uh comes
in and solves really good problems for
me and uh i may change my point of view
about it i'm not religious about
anything i will go with whatever works
so let me just make a point on that
i remember the first time i saw a
giraffe in africa on the savannah
and instead of seeing it in a zoo where
it looks like the most ungained ungainly
ridiculous animal i suddenly realized
how beautifully it was designed
yeah could the problem not be
that
we have always misinstantiated
supersymmetry causing it to be
relatively ugly even to mathematicians
and that in fact it has infected
all sorts of areas of mathematics we
can't quite keep it out it does occur in
you know local formulas for example for
the atiya singer families index theorem
uh
is it not the case that perhaps the
problem
goes back to what i was trying to say
about popper that
when something is
misinstantiated it does not invalidate
in some sense the soul
of the idea
and that what you see is is that a lot
of these ideas are misinstantiated
causing people to get crazy they see
something that is in fact not seen by
others and then when they realize that
they're in possession of something
incomplete as it may be
they rush to over instantiate it and
that that's really the problem and that
in fact frank has been driven slightly
mad
by expecting that the supersymmetry
would occur in the most naive possible
way just as georgia and glacial were
looking for proton decay in south dakota
abandoned mines
and didn't find it just as ed whitton
was looking for a very simple story
about the einstein equations coming out
of pieces of string with the anomaly
cancellation showing the way and that
over and over again
um
sabine is actually just in in some ways
doing a great job calling out many more
powerful people for not actually getting
things right but has herself fallen in
love with the idea that beauty is the is
the source of the problem maybe the
source of the problem
is is that we keep seeing glimmers of
the truth that are almost always
misinstantiated and that the real
problem is is that we are at the end and
it is the conceptual difficulties
that are the biggest problem when we say
theory of everything what do we even
mean we have these incredibly childish
conversations do we need a theory of
everything what good is the theory of
everything but i think that the much
more interesting question is
conceptually do we even know what we
mean because to the best of my knowledge
even though i'm assured that every
theorist has a private collection of
theories of everything in a drawer that
they show no one i've actually never
seen a competent attempt at a theory of
everything from anyone it's so difficult
we are in such a straight jacket at the
moment that anybody who knows anything
about this field effectively won't
produce a theory of everything candidate
because it's instantly laughable and
that in fact we don't even know what
we're talking about when we say the
words theory of everything because what
does that mean yeah
right the uh i think you really got it
when you think when you said perhaps we
do
are using
the correct
structures the correct theoretical
models we're just instantiating them
incorrectly
and i think that could very well be the
case with supersymmetry and how it's
instantiated it could be
instantiated in a different way where it
still maintains a form of supersymmetry
but
you don't end up with super partners you
don't end up with super particles bingo
so it could be something just like that
and that that's very much in the case if
you look at the brst
uh technique for
um
ghosts for gage theory with ghosts
which are essentially you know they're
they're it's a super symmetry but it's
not a super partner super symmetry
and that and in that sense it's a much
prettier structure and i think something
like that could be happening and it
could be happening over and over again
where we actually are dealing with
almost exactly the right picture we were
just a little off so totally missed it
what if what if the idea is in fact that
you're you've got
clark kent and superman and you imagine
that clark kent is something called
spider-man
uh and that uh superman is in fact peter
parker and you keep waiting for peter
parker and spider-man and you haven't
put together you have clark kent
and superman i mean there are all sorts
of things
that can explain all sorts of older
people going completely insane because
they grew up
the reason this happens is because when
we're students and we learn this stuff
we see the one way that was done
specifically and we we now are familiar
with the one way it was done
specifically and we lose track of the
fact after what after hundreds of people
have learned it this way we lose track
of the way that it could have been done
slightly different if they just made a
slightly different choice of path well
and also that when when you allow older
people to wrap their loving hands around
the necks of anybody who would come to
disagree with them financially what you
do is you interfere with the scientific
process
and it's certainly very expensive
waiting for planck's
aphorism to come true that science
progresses funeral by funeral it doesn't
need to if you solve the problem of
political economy and if there are any
billionaires out there who would like to
advance the human species
there's nothing you could do better than
free the people who need to be freed
from the economic tyranny of the elders
to actually develop the ideas that they
believe in so that we don't keep
investing in the failed ideas of other a
huge missed opportunity
if only if you knew a billionaire i mean
it would be so convenient if that were
the case um or me jim simons is
available i hope and jim has been
incredibly uh
generous in trying to figure out what to
fund i do not understand if i were jim
simons and i wanted to leave the maximal
stain and the human i mean
this isn't said because we want jim
simon's money if jim simons wanted to do
the maximal amount of good i believe
that jim simons could solve this problem
overnight because it to be honest a lot
of this is incredibly cheap
yeah
yeah when i when i hear that of course
i'm reminded of the quote by upton sun
claire that it's difficult to get a man
to understand something when his salary
depends on his not understanding it and
you know wonder what about the people
out there who say you guys are
controversial you guys are working at
this uh you know kind of outsiders
perspective i know eric hates this but
like at least this guy uh
norbert you know he's written a book
and and he's got his book he's not doing
a ted talk like like garrett uh he's
he's not doing joe rogan as uh as as
eric does
what do you say to people like that i
mean is this guy should you just should
you just humor a person like this and
and he might be listening i hope he is
norbert you're all more power to you uh
for doing you look through the book what
do you think of it well i just got it
this morning and it's a hundred and
ninety pages but it's it's gonna require
that you can figure out very quickly
whether or not i did link to it yeah so
i literally got it as i was setting up
uh to interview garrett i i will look
through it because actually it's it's a
tradition of mine to never throw away a
book i don't care what it's about uh or
whatever even if it's my own book uh
which i do you mind if i yeah
i answer that because
some books you have to throw down with
great force
um because there was a slight
implication there i will point out that
i actually don't
i've been very fascinated by the fact
that i said a quite quite a lot of
things in the geometric unity lecture
that i released
and the claim that you can't understand
anything from a lecture is itself
preposterous i remember very well when
the
what became to be known as the cyborg
whitten equations
were discussed at a seminar at mit i
guarantee you the math community did not
wait for a paper they immediately tore
into a guy named brian knutson i believe
asked edwin well what are these
equations and ed wrote them on the board
the rest is history
the claim that in some sense
you know paper or didn't happen
this kind of internet
tomfoolery has just showed you the
degradation in the communications
between the scientific community name
calling in innuendo is
really trading at a premium one of the
things that i really like about the
conversation that we have been having is
that it's nuanced
i may resent ed whitton's leadership of
the physics community but i absolutely
love his mind and what he's done sabina
pisses me off with her diplomacy which
she says i'm too busy to read this stuff
when she actually means i don't think
it's good enough to warrant my attention
or
my point is is that there's a tremendous
amount of love in this situation
uh for the com and compassion for the
people who are in this game when you
hold up that book
i see an earnest person who's almost
certainly going to be wrong
who's trying and i think that there's a
beautiful thing that goes back to david
e kaplan
at
johns hopkins who did the film particle
fever who's an unbelievable guy and i
hope you have him on your podcast
because he is an honest broker
what he said is
the entire circus
of theoretical physics is what humanizes
us the charlatans the careerists the
backstabbing the
missed opportunities the failings and
ultimately the successes that the entire
circus is in fact man trying to
understand his own condition it is we as
the ai attempting to learn our own
source code we have emerged in the
system out of nothing it is as if we've
been given a game of life in conway's
sense
and we have somehow spontaneously
erupted to try to figure out what are we
or if you want to look at it as
wheeler's the the universe inspecting
itself which he drew as a you with an
eyeball looking at itself yeah and i
think that part of the thing that you
would say is is that under david
kaplan's concept of the physics circus
whoever's book that is i may never have
heard of that person
that person is trying and you know
rather than denigrating that person
i can prove it to you on one leg that
that criticism is bs because look behind
me here
uh
this way
this way here this purple kind of book
right there
is wolfram a project
uh for theoretical physics okay so a
project to find the fundamental theory
of physics okay so he published a book
people don't read it the same people who
say the same stuff about the two of you
say the same stuff about wolf from so
that is proof positive that a book is
meaningless a paper is meaningless
having written what do they say about
the two of us well i think what they say
about the two of you is eric and you and
i have had this conversation i'm not
saying it behind your back that you are
an extraordinarily privileged human
being who uh did you know went to
harvard went to uh mit went to israel
had all these post-docs now he's in a
high-powered position you call yourself
not a physicist but you really are a
physicist to shield yourself from the
criticism that he should know better
because he's a physicist you use this as
a as a shield as armor to protect
yourself garrett they say he's not uh he
he's not traditional academic role he
didn't you guys are going to [ __ ]
kill me but i don't care i'm thousands
of miles away but they'll say garrett is
is a showman he is bright but his
potential is not being used because he
has enough gifts and they say the same
about you eric that you should be doing
this full-time and i don't agree with
that because i think you guys are making
valuable contributions arguably garrett
you know
if you break any more bones i'm going to
get pissed off at you but but actually
brian yeah what you're saying if that
was said publicly those people would be
short
and i want to bring up a very important
story there's a difference between
trying to snipe and trying to block
i said some very tough things about ed
whitton
it's very hard for me to say that
because this is a guy that i admire
effectively almost more than anyone else
a lot right when people refuse to go
short in public
and they snipe behind backs it's really
remarkable in some sense how at least
jacques destler and garibaldi his
co-author went short garrett lisi this
is the manner by which erwin chargaff
went short watson and crick
and there was nothing quite as beautiful
as watching chargaff come to understand
how deeply and painfully he had gotten
things wrong
and i think that one of the things
that's very interesting is
if people say that you know if i called
myself a physicist i guarantee you
tomorrow that criticism would convert
180 degrees
or pi radians if you like and that is it
would be how dare he call himself a
physicist he took one semester of
mechanics wtf
okay
the key point is most people are very
reluctant with love and care to say what
they mean and go short what they mean
and if i were to offer would you care to
give me ten thousand to one odds on
geometric unity
i guarantee they'd say well let's bet a
hundred bucks at one to one no no if
it's quite so ridiculous if it's funny
if it's uh if it's an internet job it's
stunned i would be very interested in
taking your house
and i'd be willing to put up you know a
little bit of money given that it's such
an outside bet so if you're interested
in going short that's not the problem
the problem is the sniping the problem
is the [ __ ] catty little comments
um and and the avoidance you know i mean
i i definitely can tell you that
i have a lot of admiration for example
as to what sean carroll has been doing
in terms of trying to push out various
aspects of the toolkit of theoretical
physics to a world audience but i also
find that there is an aspect of
avoidance
and in the case of you
you are actually saying i want to sample
what life there is
and
it's very important to recognize that
the difference between blocking
and shorting is very important if people
will not professionally go short and say
i think that the odds that you have
anything are minuscule and not worth
worrying about
that becomes very interesting because
that's something that can be falsified
well how about it you uh shall we shall
we make it interesting garrett you guys
are known for winning bets with famous
nobel laureates uh guys care to make it
interesting
but how about this how about we bet well
no that wouldn't be uh going short and i
was going to say eric betts that
garrett's right garrett bets that eric's
right but i'm trying to achieve comity
but that's a problem right because
actually i think that it's benign
bigotry right i think it's on what
metric yeah i think it's benign bigotry
to say oh well it's good eric eric good
for you let me rub your your your
beautiful einsteinian i think that's
insulting and i think it's i think it's
detrimental right to say oh it's good
that and i and i do take issue with with
sabine for doing that you know basically
i think it's a cop-out she should say
what she really believes i think it's
wrong wait wait a second sabina is in a
very vulnerable position okay fine and
i'm very defensive of sabine because
sabine has huge amounts of integrity me
too i yeah i really believe that she
intends to be as diplomatic as she can
as a curmudgeon and that she's trying to
keep you know we've got one lady in in
germany trying to keep the entire field
the reason that we keep talking about
her is because of her incredible courage
and integrity
and so even though she's wrong about
beauty and garrett is wrong about e8 and
i can keep going on over and over about
what my beliefs are
the fact is these are people who are
behaving in my opinion the most
heroically and the sniping and the
bitching and the complaining and saying
well you can tell that because they're
behaving in this way if you avoid peer
review it means that look
the key issue is i keep coming on your
show brian time after time i'm on with
will check i forget who else i've been
on penrose
penrose
no we're actually out here in public and
vulnerable and the key point is if you
want to go short and you have an idea
that this is so ridiculous by all means
well here's the structure let's
structure something so that you can
express your view and then then it
becomes much more interesting to go
after well here's a conversation you and
i had when i came on the portal which
will be released by the time the second
inshallah by the time the second
kamala harris administration is uh is in
office but uh but i uh you know i said
this that they and you and i talked
about this quite candidly that nobel
prize winners have this outsized risk
reward ratio uh that doesn't favor them
either opining about the peccadillos or
flaws in new theories of everything and
also not being very willing to step out
on a limb right because they don't want
to uh you know have their reputation
they have reputation bias they have
authority bias that comes courtesy of
this look you guys both talked about
nobel prize winners and so forth and and
you know my theory on that and i'll come
out when the portal does come out the
two of us but the point being you know
there's there is this tremendous you
know risk so i don't on one hand eric
you're saying yeah we can't criticize
sabine too much because she's extremely
courageous and vulnerable and she's
doing a great job but she's not backed
by this edifice of tenure and so forth
that i enjoy um on the other hand we
can't criticize someone like wilczek
because he's not gonna take the bait and
possibly risk some of his uh hit points
and
no no no no no this is what feynman came
out against strength here and he made
the point he said when i was a young man
the old people got it wrong and so i'm
gonna be tell i'm gonna be telling you
that as an old guy
i think the string theorists have it
completely wrong now of course he didn't
really mean that he really meant i think
the straight theorists are completely
wrong i'm not here just to entertain you
the key issue is is that the old guys
who really still understood what the
game was had won enough
that they were in a position to get
things wrong and to be relatively
undamaged and undeterred the problem
that we have now is that the leading
lights of the theoretical physics
community have in general not made
contact with the unforgiving that is
they have not made contact with the
physical world they don't work in
dimensions uh or or you know space-time
signatures that are actually
real they tend to work in places where
there is no chance of bumping up against
anything other than mathematical
reality and so
by deferring that what we have is we
have very vulnerable old people we have
now have people dying at the ends of
their lives who are considered leading
lights of the physics community who have
never been proven to have accomplished
anything actually in physics
and i don't say this to be a jerk i say
this because the field is in danger when
you go for almost 50 years without
making significant contact from the
theory perspective we've had about three
or four major
updates from the experimentalists to
your point brian
you're in danger of having very
respectable people who it's not even
clear are physicists
in standard concepts of physics when you
talk about people like ed hooft and yang
and weinberg
and
frank wilcheck you're talking about an
extremely
important dwindling community like the
number of humans who have walked on the
moon
every human being who has walked on the
moon is old and everyone who has made
contact with experiment from the theory
perspective in fundamental physics is
now old this is a non-renewable resource
we are in incredible danger because we
have got to claim that the people who
sit in the chaired professorships are
incredibly accomplished but by physical
standards almost none of them are and
this is not me being a jerk this is
unfortunately the world being a jerk how
do you how do you participate
how do you instantiate that though eric
how do you look you're not coming get
your damn hands off my chair you know i
earned this chair professor behind but i
didn't say experimental no i know i'm
just joking but i am to somebody else
i'm blocking somebody else so i had this
conversation with i think it was kamran
vapha uh but it might have been somebody
else but but another person who's done a
tremendous amount of mathematical uh
things he's very brilliant i love him
he's a mensch but you know i feel like
we have we have a whole
you know glut of very accomplished
brilliant theoreticians theoretical
physicists perhaps and and there aren't
as many experimental as doing the work
as garrett said earlier you know it's
very expensive to do experiment blah
blah but um but how do you physically
get them to give it up i once proposed
in a faculty meeting and now i'm tenured
so i can say whatever i think about uh
about various ones that might no i love
my colleagues but but i said i think you
fear i should teach two classes for
every one class an experimentalist has
to teach because i'm traveling i'm going
into chile i'm going to south pole i'm
doing and i'm running an enterprise with
a budget annually of 1.7 million dollars
to fight my students for them to travel
for them to go to chile blah blah blah
and they were like if you do that
i will make your life a living hell you
know basically they're not going to
teach two classes a quarter they're not
going to do they shouldn't be teaching
for the most part how do you do that how
do you how do you instantiate this thing
of get the old boomers off this look we
have a 78 year old president right now
look you need not to get the old boomers
off the stage you need enough funding so
that young people their life
okay we're not where it's motherhood and
apple pie where do we get the money let
me ask garrett garrett
wait a second one second
i've been on this program before
the u.s government needs to recognize
that it is shooting itself in the foot
by not honoring an agreement that was
tacitly understood which is we create
your economy
and for god's sake when we tell you that
we need funding and we need some toys
shut up
do you think we're going to get that
created almost everything that is still
working no i agree 100 with you on that
obviously and i and by the way i like to
point out that nobody looked at the
equations of quantum mechanics and said
let's make a lcd transistor that will go
on a smartphone it came from
experimental physics i'm just teasing
but garrett maybe you haven't heard this
eric calls theoretical physics the seal
team 6 of intellectual capability by the
way i have a lot of friends in the other
sealed teams and they're just as
talented eric i know you mean that in
the best possible way and you've had you
know if i get taken out by seal team
three yeah
jocko's coming back for more for you
let's let me let me stop and take a
pause for one second just to remind
people please do subscribe to the
podcast please leave a comment uh what
do you think about these different
theories of eric's and and garrett's and
what do you think about the importance
of i believe popularization that these
are two of the greatest exponents i
think sabine is an incredible expositor
she takes things in a different
direction than i do people that are
actually doing research and and taking
courageous stands you'll be pleased to
know that people like my friend and and
upcoming guest avi loeb he is very much
in the same camp as you guys and he's a
theoretical astrophysicist and he
believes that there's tremendous amounts
of evidence for the existence of
extraterrestrial intelligence that's not
being funded just the exact same
arguments that eric and garrett might
make because of all the intellectual air
being sucked out and the financial
capital getting sucked out so eric has
made um controversial to me suggestions
that we should tax semiconductor
instructions or somehow monetize these
inventions of physics i pointed out eric
i think when you and i and max tegmark
were on together earlier this month i'll
put a link somewhere in the notes to
that i pointed out that we're doing it
again garrett we're doing it again we
don't never learn our lessons quantum
computing the next big thing it's going
to you know revolutionize our
understanding artificial intel we
invented that in the form of what are
called justice injunctions and i had uh
i had john press go on about that and we
talked about quantum computing we're
doing it all over again when will we
ever learn how would you solve it how i
mean are you optimistic garrett
politically speaking that the new
administrations are going to be more
favorable to science and more
importantly to physics specifically in
terms of direct funding
i think the new administration is
definitely more favorable to science
certainly to listening to scientists if
not actually financially supporting them
but i think some financial support will
come just with the added respect
but respect isn't enough to put food on
the table you also need financial
support
and i think you know pulling from my own
story
uh my advisor in quantum field 3 passed
away and i was pretty much left adrift
but i had
you know somehow somewhat miraculously
come up with my own financial support if
you're getting lucky in the stock market
so i was able to go off on my own do my
own thing
and got lucky with it
now i'm a horrible data point right
out there survivor bias yeah
but
uh i think the best thing you could
possibly do
to get young people out from the tyranny
of control from the out from elders
and allow them to explore
their own ideas their own creations
their their own explorations in
mathematical physics quantum computing
and everything
uh is to get your fingers off of their
endeavors
i mean this this happened with fqxi
where they started out it's like well
you know
take proposals for all new weird ideas
and give money out based on those ideas
and see where it goes and i had a weird
idea i've submitted it i got funded wow
this is amazing that was great it all
went into stocks now i've got a house um
the
but what happened to fqxi is now it's
changed and now it's directed now that
it's like well we will we will accept
research proposals on this one specific
area of interpretations of quantum
mechanics and its relation to
consciousness and i'm like oh jesus all
right they're gone get too much
transparency too much best practices too
much administrative knowledge all this
stuff all this over management has to go
what you really want to do
is
have some rich patron say i'm just going
to give a lot of money to a lot of smart
young people and let them have fun
just take really smart people give them
money give them the support they need
maybe point them towards the community
of people they can talk to
and let them and just support them and
let them do what you want don't say it
is fun garrett
look they they need to have houses and
and children yeah they need they need to
have a future i mean the perimeter
institute came close to that right you
guys see you guys both just give give
more money to smart people when they're
using money to smart yeah but i i okay
so jim simon's told me that and he's
worth 20 billion dollars probably he
said if i gave a dollar to everyone who
said i'm a super genius he said even i
would be broke in other words there's
everybody thinks that there's how do you
have the how do you have the knowledge
to assay which ideas are worth pursuing
or you just give it to everybody because
then you give it to nobody tests are
pretty good even iq tests are pretty
good give it to you give give money to
the talk i'll fail i'll fail i won't get
anywhere i'll be broke
brian
the problem is is that that that's a
pretend comment
there really aren't that many people
with even a you know take every single
person that you mentioned as having an
alternative theory of everything
it's a tiny number of human beings who
are even trying
this is not like everybody you know with
a story
the community of people who are actually
trying to do something interesting from
outside with any technical competence
is relatively small and this is this is
just this is a nonsense argument for
holding on to the fact jim might be
saying something else which is
i don't think any of these people are
promising enough
fair enough yeah you know you know it
occurred to me as you're both speaking
that that you guys are both kind of like
orphans
and and and uh in terms of not having
advisors in the traditional sense um in
graduate school and i see you guys like
brothers and and brothers can be best
friends uh but they also fight as we
know from our friends kane and abel and
maybe that explains this nemesis theory
the anti-matter nemesis but and maybe it
explains the conservation of mass
between the two of you guys over the
pandemic let me
let me just pause for one i'll go ahead
eric
garrett's been shredded for a long time
and i've just lost some weight after
being uh you know too far north on the
scale so i i don't think that we should
overdo that i do think that it's really
important to recognize that
the antagonism is real the love is real
love is foreign this is normal and the
reason that this has been able to to
work as a relationship for as long as it
has
over a decade
is that we listen to each other and we
take each other seriously when i tried
to do a good job of saying why i think
garrett's theory is one of the most
interesting even though it doesn't work
it's this ability to go both long and
short and to say what's positive and
what's negative a lot of what you see
when somebody is just wholly negative
and they they say you know smart guy but
this but that but this but that but
jesus christ
that stuff is getting confusing the tiny
number of people who are doing anything
interesting including sabine
crapping all over all of us
is
that this community is fewer than 20
people
i don't think i just want to be clear
that if if jim simons doesn't have 20
bucks i confront it
right i can get him 20 bucks i told him
i told him you know if he he had a down
month this year for the first time ever
i said jim if you need a loan
eric's money is available no seriously
um i did have just one thing to say
before we turn to maybe a little bit of
politics and then we'll finish up
because it's been late and garrett's
been so kind and the waves are getting
tasty down there shakalaka garrett lisey
it is a good kite surfing day today
triton class of what what year did you
get your
phd ah good lord is either 98 or 99
beloved son
prodigal son of the university of
california san diego my beloved
institution eric weinstein proprietor of
the portal and all things
mystical magical and multifluoresce and
mellifluous i should say
eric uh you're quite an inspiration
we've had these conversations before i i
want to talk about uh this phrase that
actually garrett you said a couple
minutes ago i wasn't intending to talk
to go here but if you'll indulge me i
know eric will it's like catnip to his
newfound pet cat uh but i want to whose
name is schrodinger that was a nice
touch eric to get that cat call it
schrodinger keep it no i'm just kidding
eric doesn't have a cat yet he might but
he doesn't yet but
uh garrett you said i don't you said
listen
good one eric you said listen to
scientists now unless you said lisi to
scientists
to what extent should we listen to
scientists i mean i made this point on
the portal episode that's locked in the
vault for its controversial status
apparently i said shockley william
shockley was a scientist he he
co-created the transistor he won the
nobel prize in 1950s for its invention
he believed deeply in eugenics and the
superiority of whites over blacks robert
milliken his name has just been taken
off of caltech's milliken library for
his belief in eugenics won the nobel
prize for establishing the fundamental
quantization of electric charge
uh who james watson has said things that
rich people should be paid to have
children because their children will be
smarter than poor children these are all
scientists well my favorite one do you
guys know about fritz haber who won the
nobel prize first uh one of the first
jews to win the nobel prize he was a
german jew who in 1908 came up with the
the haber bosch process which we now
know creates fertilizer for half the
world's food production
and then he turned his attention to
chemical warfare
including overseeing a chemical strike
in brussels in belgium i believe in 1915
that killed 50 000 allied lives he was a
scientist he won the 1918 nobel prize
after
committing chemical warfare atrocities
to which germany had signed against a
treaty against these are all scientists
should we listen to them what when do we
start i'm talking about listening to
scientists about what we should do not
not what we can do
and there's a difference explain i i
think scientists are experts in what we
can do
and
a lot of other thought in ethics and
philosophy and the liberal arts
often
[Music]
areas in which our leadership is more
educated
is more expert in what we should do
and eugenics is something that we can do
we can breed for intelligence in any
creatures including us
or other traits should we do it no
so yeah listen to scientists with what
we can do and what will happen if we do
things
but not always with what we should
should do so yeah i always say science
means knowledge it doesn't mean wisdom
but eric you know to the extent that you
could maximize funding let's say that's
all you cared about doing is maximizing
science funding for the betterment and
preservation of life on this planet
which you believe is is facing an
existential crisis um as you know as
we've talked about on the into the
impossible podcast and you've talked
about in the portal etc so you think
we're facing so why not submit to rule
by scientific minds what's wrong with
that
scientists are pretty smart
well i don't like the strong many of the
questions i mean you asked a really
interesting question before so i'm going
to leave the provocation uh
and go to the original question please
uh you didn't mention paul ehrenfest who
murdered his own i think [ __ ] child
maybe with down syndrome nor did you
mention pascal jordan
uh father of quantum mechanics uh it was
a straight-up nazi to say nothing of
heisenberg's uh
dalliance uh with national socialism in
germany and frank hurts and autohan and
yep
right so i can go through this um
and
okay so now
you know this is like the moles all over
my body am i going to tear them all out
i had an african-american dermatologist
who said to me he said you know i could
remove these things but if i if i really
did what i what you want me to do you'd
have almost nothing left
and i think the key problem is that um
you have to wrestle
with scientists who have crazy ideas and
we regularly go crazy in opposite
directions you'll find people who uh you
know advocate for fascism and you'll
have people who advocate for anarchy the
issue is that the shelling points that
are attractive to the scientific mind
can be quite extreme now we can all make
fun of jim watson uh for saying a bunch
of things which you know i've spent a
week with him and let me tell you he is
attracted to outrage
and in part those outrages are
provocations the key question is well
what do you got to come back at me so i
got a chance to
sock it to jim watson over and over and
over and over again for stupid comments
about women yeah but they weren't stupid
for the reason that everybody else said
they were stupid they were stupid
because he didn't actually know his
stuff
and he knew his stuff in all sorts of
other areas it's very very scary when
extremely smart people say things that
challenge us now we can all agree that
eugenics is bad
but then when we talk about oh well this
embryo apparently may have a bracket
gene in it do you want that removed if
we have the ability to remove it then
we're all going to say oh no no no why
why doom somebody to a radical
mastectomy later in life well guess what
suddenly you're practicing eugenics and
you know what when you take somebody out
to dinner in a movie to figure out
whether they're an appropriate mate
you're practicing weak eugenics so part
of the problem is is that it's much
easier
to
pretend that all of these people have
gone completely insane and that they're
just ridiculous and it's much harder to
say well if a leading mind is making
this point do they have something so my
question is are you afraid of jim watson
are you afraid secretly that he might
actually be saying something if so by
all means
suppress him you know
but in fact if i believe that jim watson
is not correct about most of these
things i would much rather share a stage
with him and go toe to toe and make the
point that part of what's motivating him
is that he wanted to be free and he saw
the degradation of freedom inside of the
academy and he became more and more
obstinate mischievous and as i've said
the problem is that the legacy of jim
watson is so important that it cannot be
left to jim watson
jim watson did so much and his story
means so much and his stupid ass stuff
that he says late in life because he
feels that his freedom has been eroded
and that other people haven't understood
now jim watson has a lot of points many
of them bad
and edward teller would be another
example the person who along with stan
ulam
unlocked the unlock the power of the sun
so that we can wield it against our
enemies giving us the power of gods and
almost certainly dooming us to die on
this planet was in fact arguably a
humanitarian that no one understood and
if you go back to his letter with leo to
leo zillard
where he talks about the fact he said we
cannot pretend that we have not
allowed the genie to escape from its
bottle and our only hope is convincing
us that war is an unthinkable prospect
it's not at all clear to me that when
you remove teller's name from a building
that you're doing humanity as service
because you didn't understand it if i
tell you that if you read gandhi in the
original it's very clear that he was
pro-violence
now you can decide that he's wrapped in
a doty so and he's a kindly old man who
freed india from british tyranny
just because of his desire for pacifism
but gandhi hated pacifism with a passion
and he far preferred violence to
pacifism
and part of the problem is that we have
too many children running around the
stage pretending that they have some
idea about what happened historically
and who are afraid because they're
incapable of wrestling with the most
dangerous ideas that are extolled by
some scientists so my feeling is that
the answer to bad scientific
proclamations where scientists are
saying things that are unforgivable that
are dangerous is better scientists
and the right way to solve this problem
is allow people to share the stage with
jim watson and humiliate him
when he goes after something that isn't
true and if he says something that's
horrible
that in fact
we can't figure out what to say back to
him then that tells us that we're going
to have to wrestle with that sooner or
later yeah and part of the problem is is
that we've all become incredible [ __ ]
because simply having the word eugenics
put next to your name is now the kiss of
death but when it comes to somebody
who's talking about bracket genes you're
going to decide that the russell
conjugation is that this is
compassionate uh genetics well guess
what jim watson has a lot of compassion
and he's got a lot of stupidity and he's
got a tremendous amount of genius and
originality and we can either be [ __ ]
about the whole thing or we can decide
that effectively science is an absolute
defense if you are behaving
scientifically
you are going to in fact be vindicated
sooner or later and so what we should do
is we should say is the real problem
that we are afraid that scientists may
tell us things that we don't want to be
true or is the real problem that we're
afraid that they're going to say wrong
things and that they're going to be so
emboldened by their credentials that
it's going to pick up an extra boost and
what my claim is is that mostly what
we're doing is that we're living in fear
you can't trust scientists by the way if
you don't give them intellectual freedom
and enough resources is a part of
intellectual freedom so part of the
problem is you can't trust scientists
now because everybody's living grant to
grant hand to mouth and in fear of their
colleagues if you in fact go back to
academic freedom you will find that the
scientific community is one of the best
groups to advise you and one of the
things that they will tell you is that
they shouldn't be put simply in
leadership positions that but they they
should be advising people who are
extremely good at leadership and what we
need right now is to if eric lander if
you're out there what a pleasure to see
you coming in
uh don't overdo it with the biology you
have a history with mathematics with all
sorts of different areas you know how
important physics is make sure that you
have people from a tiny group of people
who are still really doing physics and
mathematics and all of these beautiful
things computing to give you the advice
and we're so lucky to have a polymath of
your quality uh advising the president i
don't
yeah and another i don't have a lot of
faith in joe biden but i can tell you
one thing that pick
really excited me
please just restore something like uh
the the traditional relationship between
science and governance and uh francis
arnold
also as a selection made me very happy
although i was a little bit you know
dismayed that it's all applied it's
attacking covid which is important and
quantum information which is important
but nothing about the pure essence of
the heart of reality that gives so much
interest to the animated discussion that
we've had today just in the last few
minutes we we have remaining
i'd like to turn to something lighter
and a little bit more relaxing so um
garrett what do you think about abortion
no uh i want to ask you
uh so garrett how do you oh that's
how do you strike a balance uh between
kind of the expansion of the mind and
the body uh and so forth kind of your
spiritual side what's your daily routine
like what you know what what what
animates you you know just to that gives
you life i i always think physics is
what makes uh is is what defends the
planet but the arts are what make the
planet worth defending something clumsy
like that uh but tell me something gary
yeah what what is the day in the life of
garrett lisey like and what sort of like
an ideal future for you and maybe for
the for the whole planet
well i mean eric really
uh
described it well when he said that if
you're hyper focused on just one subject
and throwing all your time and effort
into it you're either gonna mistakenly
think
in a megalomaniacal fashion that you
have discovered and commanded all
knowledge and are all-knowing or you
think you're like a horrible failure and
totally worthless imposter
yeah so the answer is don't focus on
just one thing
um you can have one high-risk play
uh great put some attention into that
put someone working with that and i do
that that's my physics research
um you also need some sort of project
you can throw yourself into that's
guaranteeing success
um that's what the pacific science
institute has been for me if you you
know if you give a place in maui where
scientists can come and hang out and
have a good time and enjoy the island
and go around and talk with them and
teach them how to surf and kite surf and
have a good time that's guaranteed
success there's no way that's going to
fail
well it didn't work so well in hoboken
the hoboken sciences institute i'm just
kidding i love new jersey
i'm not in new jersey i'm joking
so so yeah this has been this has been
fantastic and right now it's it's just
my house which has delusions of grandeur
but you know i'm hoping to grow it
and
uh so that's been fantastic and i tried
to uh so i spent a lot of my time doing
that i spent a lot of my time playing
outside staying healthy surfing
kitesurfing paragliding just doing
ridiculously fun stuff i like to do
something fun outside preferably in the
ocean every day for a few hours
which is great um i also spend a lot of
time
reading about what my friends and other
people are doing around the world
whether it be on social media or in
different news sources
um i'll also keep me up on blogs keeping
up with other papers people have written
um but also so i try to balance things i
try to balance between like time with my
girlfriend very important
um
time time with friends hanging out and
socializing which has been a little
harder with the pandemic going on but
still possible with the
with the more restricted pot of social
interactions but really getting out in
nature and enjoying nature which is
still very healthy and very protective
health wise
uh is is probably my main thing would
you say you're a spiritual person by any
means
um
no i am not spiritual or religious good
okay
fair enough i'm surrounded by a lot of
spiritual but not religious and i'm
neither okay outside of physics who
would you most want to
you know share a mai tai with
uh i don't drink so well virgin mai tai
who says i'll have margarita every once
in a while
um the
uh
outside of physics even in history
let's go let's go historical even uh
satoshi nakamoto
all right you guys can't all right now
we're gonna do it now we're going there
we got a lot of questions about bitcoin
you opened it up eric thoughts on
bitcoin you tweeted about it recently
tell me about bitcoin well i just want
to get rid of the blockchain so that
it's actually a locally enforced
conservation law that replaces space
time with a system of computer nodes and
i believe that because
geometry engage theory is the one system
that we believe never throws an
exception
it's important if we're going to use
this to actually
liberate us from the tyranny of
abundance and to bring back scarcity so
that the markets don't cause us to have
to embrace authoritarianism
satoshi if you're out there
i very much want to talk to you about
getting rid of bitcoin and moving to a
standard beyond the blockchain so that
tokens like gold have no stench
and i'm very worried about
recent comments of janet yellen
which seem to indicate that
people who play with fiat money
remember that
if you can't govern you must print
and when people print bitcoin does well
because bitcoin can't
right and so effectively the main use
case for bitcoin is hedging people who
are incompetent and therefore must print
uh by giving them an alternative where
the fed can't get it so the key problem
is is that a government uh according to
weber is a monopoly on violence and so
if you can't actually break
um
elliptic curve cryptography or whatever
it is that you're using to protect
crypto um because
it's a it's a coin
determined not by cryptography rather
than violence
what we're going to do is we're going to
bring violence to those who hold that
which is enforced by mathematics so it's
incredibly important first of all to get
rid of the blockchain
to make sure that it has no stench to
see whether or not we cannot base it on
something like a gauge theory because
what this is is one of the most
important intellectual developments of
our lifetime why is that the fact that
it makes people you say that one second
okay go ahead the fact that it makes
people rich has confused us about what
happened
what happened is that locally enforced
conservation laws which are
unfortunately non-locally recorded
have been found to be done autonomously
in a distributed fashion
and this thing effectively allows us to
recreate the physical world inside of a
computer world the great danger of
computers is that they've turned as mark
andreessen says software eats the world
that means that things that previously
were not public goods and services
become
public goods because they're in exhaust
small files are inexhaustible and
inexcludable if they're not protected
ergo the market cannot see them
therefore value and price gap this is
one of the greatest dangers
because it allows in tyranny when the
market stops being able to function the
dream of abundance that is common in
mill valley and at burning man is in
fact a great danger to our society that
almost nobody has commented upon
and bringing scarcity into the digital
world potentially allows the markets to
function so that we do not need uh
authorities telling us what we can and
can't do and effectively if you want to
protect freedom you are going to have to
probably bring back scarcity because the
tyranny of abundance
threatens to undermine our civilization
and i know that that's going to be very
unfamiliar to many people so satoshi i'm
pretty sure that if you're out there and
i believe you're probably a collective
rather than an individual it would be a
pleasure
if i kept geometric unity uh quiet for
decades um i guarantee you that uh i can
keep a secret it would be
tremendously useful to try to liberate
your great invention from the tyranny of
the blockchain let me just say one thing
about that so i had michael saylor on
last week a very provocative gentleman
also
also aligned with some of the things
eric is interested in peter thiel is
interested in
decentralizing academia at least at the
uh at the undergraduate level making all
education free for millions of people
around the world a technical education
specifically
and uh but i said to him i said you know
nothing that complicated about
blockchain i said you know it's
cryptographic there's there's essence of
it is could have been done in the 1980s
so why wasn't it done sooner eric or
garrett uh whoever wants to answer why
i mean why did it come about when it did
is it is it and is it the fact that it
has this first mover advantage the only
kind of secret that it has that it is
the peter tellian monopoly that uh cures
all ills i guess eric you can start
no it isn't
um we need something better than bitcoin
i do think that it could have been done
earlier but i think that the fact
you know as i point out the rollerboard
suitcase was only invented in 1989 and
ben franklin could have done it in
general we decide that someone is a
genius because it's cheaper than
pointing out that the rest of us are
morons
and satoshi in fact um
you know was the only non-moronic
individual many people had this idea i
believe that you know peter thiel and
elon musk were on this idea and that
became paypal and they couldn't actually
pull it off so let's just be glad that
somebody was not confused because
certainly i didn't think of how to do
this and i would point out that when it
comes around that bitcoin doesn't solve
everything and its successor gets rid of
the blockchain and you have perfect uh
distributed computing without leaving a
stench
you're going to have a very interesting
situation where we're all going to have
to explain why we were so moronic that
we didn't realize that the blockchain
could have been disintermediated as well
yeah there is a negative uh with with
bitcoin with its energy usage
and that's a that could end up being a
very expensive mistake
so uh but other than that i think it's a
freaking fantastic idea and i'm
definitely long it so and i i and i
don't know as far as what you're
describing maybe our universe is
unfolding as some alien civilizations
blockchain
growing so
well maybe we are the computation of
some uh very complicated hash that's
trying to get 10 to the 20 zeros for the
for our knots when the
when our lives are done
you're probably in an entirely natural
universe as far as i can tell all right
guys well we set a record for one of the
longest continuous streams that at least
my bladder can tolerate
thank you guys uh for your you're not
catheter how are you guys even surviving
right now oh yeah well you'll learn when
you get to be a pilot that your bladder
can uh when you get your license that
you could get an extra bladder that's a
paragliding thing like so if you see
like cross-country paragliders uh each
of those guys has a tube going down
their leg and that's how they stay in
the air so long you don't need a tube i
found actually
the yellow rain as uh over over san
diego
uh guys any last things you want to plug
or spin uh garrett what's next on the
horizon for you i'll point out we did do
a live stream right before this live
streams find that on the into the my
youtube channel please uh subscribe to
their twitter accounts i've listed them
there at garrett lisey eric r weinstein
please subscribe to the portal podcast
please subscribe to the into the
impossible podcast leave a review in a
rating etc uh it really helps us out we
got avilobe coming up we have a deepak
chopra coming up again and we're going
to have a phenomenal conversation with
carlo ravelli stay tuned for that lee
smullen and uh and some on some people
that you might not have heard of that
i'm trying to get on to uh to really
boost up some of the signals that are
out there a critical biography of even
hawking has just been published or will
be published that's going to be
discussed in march or april whenever it
comes out by a professor at nyu anyway i
want to uh thank you guys anything you
guys want out there
yeah
i'm concerned that i may be booted off
of social media
with everything that's going on it would
be great if you wanted to stay in touch
to get your email address i think eric
weinstein.org
is a means where they can't
disintermediate
i don't know that they can throw me
well with what's going on i'm very
worried about uh redoing operation
chokepoint in the biden
administration because well he did not
win with a mandate from the electorate
the capitol hill insurrection is being
treated as a mandate and i think that
you have to very much fear the idea that
we've figured out that if we have no
public options to communicate with each
other then all speech can actually be
controlled uh through private companies
and the great danger at the moment is we
have to be able to stay in touch so if
you can find my rss you don't have to go
through apple or spotify
and if you can give me your email
address at ericweinstein.org
i will attempt uh to get myself kicked
off of social media by saying reasonable
things throughout the year all right
like me i'm going to go down and which
is incredibly important i'm going to go
down in a blaze
here yeah yeah i'm going to go down in a
blaze of incompetence
carrying your corner that way yeah so
yeah i mean i was i was worried about
that as well and i mean
i think it's unusual eric for the first
time in human history the media is not
really beholden to a profit margin we
have the world's richest man controlling
the washington post and love them or
hate them uh that's just the fact that
it no longer has a profit motive
whatsoever uh and similar for other news
outlets and didn't know elon had bought
it
maybe the second second richest one
that was
yeah
so uh the other yeah
i do worry about that and i wonder in
the public's interest it's in the
interest of of honesty you know when
amazon has access i mean didn't barack
obama once say you didn't build that you
know referring to the internet backbone
this is very dangerous it's very
dangerous we're entering a period of a
authoritarianism where the idea is that
the the price of keeping you safe will
be your freedom
and i'm saying that from the left of
center uh my friends on the right of
center are more commonly saying that and
it is incredibly important that we
recognize that we want some risk
uh particularly we may have a reason to
control the speech when it's targeted at
individuals but controlling speech
around ideas is a one-way ticket to help
to hell we're going to have to tolerate
unsafe thought unsafe ideas and even
unsafe safe people and the current panic
around safety not being
weighed against the risks of
authoritarian control of what we can say
and to whom we can say it
is a giant glaring error and the only
way that this is possible is if no
sensible people are ever let
let onto mainstream media and at the
moment there is a blockade of an entire
wing which i would say is the smart wing
of american politics who you will never
see featured on msnbc and increasingly
not even on npr and i think people have
to recognize that what we've seen is a
major transformation where you are not
allowed to communicate with people who
will challenge the dominant narrative
what what feedback did you get after
going courageously on gret glenn beck's
show you're not on the right that's
clear you're not fitting anywhere you're
schrodinger's pundit uh when you put
that on but uh what's been the reaction
how come you don't get invited to go on
shows with your comrades literally and
on the left how come that's not
happening how do we how do we approach
that subject i mean people like ezra
klein have gone on ben shapiro show a
mutual friend of ours but you know how
do we get to the to the you know the the
young turks how do we get the message
that you have
to the to your side
it's not the young turks i mean is uh as
dan drezner uh washington post
contributor said everything that i i
have to say that's new is not true and
everything that i have to say that's
true is not new so in fact part of the
problem is is that i am one of the least
interesting people on earth
uh somehow i'm actually a [ __ ] i have
nothing interesting to say nothing to
contribute and that is undoubtedly why
you're listening to brian williams and
mara gay on msnbc explain uh how if um
bloomberg's campaign money were only
redistributed we would all be
millionaires
right now there's a blockade of reality
because the business model of the
democratic party has been shifted away
from labor and actually expensive things
like medic medicare and education all
the things that we need to do and in
fact identity to my wife pia milani's
point is the cheapest substitute the
problem is that the traditional
democratic party would have to be going
after its own donor class and so as a
result the affiliated media that we've
previously trusted to call balls and
strikes has never been perfect it's
never been as bad as this and the
transformation that we're seeing is
effectively a blockade of all people of
courage and intellect who are no longer
welcome if they will not file a flight
plan uh with traditional media and
traditional media was will go after each
one of them and they'll tell you that
they're part of extremism
they're the alt-right they're the far
right et cetera et cetera uh the reason
what you asked about glenn beck
the amount of love
that glenn beck and i generated from not
agreeing with each other except on the
issue
of civility
brotherhood togetherness
going forward
it's electrifying and everything that
breaks up the business model that is
division will no longer be welcome and
that's what's going on is that if you're
not a division merchant
you will find that in effect
you can no longer speak i used to be
welcome at the new york times washington
post
npr i am no longer welcome and it is
clear that the transformation has
occurred the font is the same at the new
york times but the contents and the
writers are totally different a
tremendous transformation has happened
and i beg of you to listen to the fact
that there are a large number of people
particularly on the left who have been
told that they are no longer on the left
and that we've each individually been
isolated and one of the great things
about recording something like this is
we can say to each other hey are you
still here yes i'm still here what's
going on is that npr and the new york
times and msnbc will not communicate
that many of us are fed up as is the
right with the current direction of
where everything is about identity
diversity inclusion and in fact many of
us who have fought for diversity and
inclusion my family for over 100 years
are appalled at the current version of
these things not because we don't want a
more equal more just more reasonable
society but because demonizing people
who speak the truth and intimidating
people with cancer culture so that they
can't feed their families is not the way
to a prosperous future and so it's
incredibly important to leave these
channels open so that we can humiliate
the blockade of reality that's coming
through the people who traditionally
were responsible for making sure that
reality at least had a first draft in
the form of journalism
now let's talk about the problems of
gmos okay
eric uh that's phenomenal and the last
thing i'll say yes i was very proud of
you as i always am but you spoke up
about this ap story that the last
frontier of the radicals is on the
podcast era and i i got shivers about
that because you know who's to say that
because i had you on my show not to you
know i've had noam chomsky on my show
i've also had ben shapiro on my show
michael knowles and i did a podcast
together as you did with michael moles
so you know the question is are they
what are they gonna who are they gonna
come for next and then who speaks for
the last person you know the first they
came for the gays i didn't speak because
i wasn't gay first then they came for
the communists come for me
this is my this is my request i've built
an enormous audience
you want to play this game come for me
i'm willing to say all sorts of things
that you don't want said i want to make
it easy you want to boot me off
you twitter safety
are you interested in getting rid of me
come for me
what i'm asking increasingly
is is that those of us stop we stop
cowering you know if this is the land of
the free in the home of the brave we
cannot sit around saying oh my god
somebody's going to call me a racist
yeah i'm a leader of the alt-right i'm a
nazi named weinstein
jesus christ
the
but let's just look at how funny and
ridiculous these morons are who are
dividing us we need to approach them
with love and compassion they've chosen
a terrible path and they've radicalized
us and you know i believe that donald
trump was a very dangerous thing to do
but the reason that we had donald trump
is that the left conjured him out of the
vacuum by denying increasing amounts of
of of reality and what is necessary is
yeah i'm sure i'm going to get canceled
i'm sure that they're going to come
after me okay we've got to welcome the
fight and the battle and we're not all
going to make it but this country was
not built by people cowering under their
goddamn kitchen tables
so enough yeah you can go to normandy
and uh and and give up your life at age
18. we can certainly speak out on behalf
of free speech ironically enough the
last freedom that we might enjoy in the
bill of rights yes
as i said uh you want to see male
privilege take a look at the at the
names on the vietnam memorial wall you
know i mean cut it out grow up
just if you're going to come after
somebody come after people who are in a
position to take it because we've been
on the left the whole time and if you
think you're going to claim that i'm a
member of the alt-right boy are we going
to have an entertaining tango
i just all i do is i ask you to dance
well eric um i salute your courage
garrett i salute your ingenuity and your
courage and uh and i and i feel like
these kinds of conversations are really
more valuable than ever and and as i
said uh many times in the past you know
when i have to talk to people for work
it's because i have to talk to them when
i get to talk to you my friends it's
because i want to talk to you guys uh
you guys give me so much inspiration and
and really for my whole audience i know
i'm speaking on behalf of sorry i didn't
take too many questions today uh you
guys can unsubscribe i hope you won't
but uh i can't i can't resist when i
have such uh such delightful uh company
as these two gentlemen i hope you'll do
a part two maybe sometime down the road
a little bit as time goes on garrett
anything last that you want to put in a
quick plug for before cancel you maybe
no i i will be uh extremely disturbed if
uh social media moves to block eric in
significant ways that is extremely
disturbing to me because you've always
been a incredibly intellectual and
rational voice online and with your
growing army
uh
addressing different issues it's been
incredibly good to follow and see that
growth and i really really will be
disturbed if you're silenced in in ways
so i don't want to see that and as a
source of integrity yeah um
uh i'm not selling anything i'm also
shallow enough to be on instagram if you
want to if people want to follow me
there
and see fun pictures of maui and so
forth which is uh as brian said a little
more on the light side yeah um and i
think light is important with a lot of
dark things having happened and
currently going on
uh having more light in our lives is
extremely important yeah so um anyway
like i said i'm not selling anything
uh and
i don't have any deep politically
motivated missions that's right uh i'm
just trying to have a good time yeah and
contribute to the pacific science yes i
mean i think it's a great thing that
you've set up and people can find where
can they find that if they want to make
a donation putting up the putting up the
website
or yeah i'll put up the website right
now yeah sorry uh we we didn't get to
take too many questions from the
audience but but yes i implore you i put
up eric's website right now is on the is
on the screen
eric weinstein.org and then pacific
science institute dot org is garrett's
uh garrett echoing what you said as
martin luther king said once
only light can drive out darkness i
think um i'm optimistic i i don't know
if it's going to be you know this rosy
rosie everything's uphill from here but
i do believe that there's uh just
incredible potential around the corner
and as uh as an astronomer i don't fear
the darkness i welcome the darkness but
uh but i always know to be happy when
there are rays of light and you guys are
rays of light in my life you inspire me
you inspire my audience thank you so
much for going into the impossible with
me please stay in touch
brianketingduck.com
and eric weinstein.org and
pacificscienceinstitute.org you guys are
much more philanthropic than i am i
guess i'll take you out with a uh with
an outro for my good friend and veteran
miguel tully who is the proprietor of
the yeti tears instagram account and
also on youtube he's made some lovely
sketches of eric he's made some artwork
for me which you can see maybe in the
background and he made this instrumental
track to take us out thank you so much
everyone be well be safe enjoy this
precious gift of life that we all have
suck the marrow out like garrett and
don't be afraid as eric has taught us to
take on giants goodbye everybody thank
you so much
thank you great talking with you brian
and you too eric
great being with you guys
love you guys
[Music]
thank you all for going into the
impossible a little different a little
different episode for the today's choice
but i hope you will say subscribed as i
mentioned katie freeze is coming on the
show she's one of the mothers of dark
matter uh that we low and love and oh
our existence to she'll be on the show
in two weeks this tuesday avi loeb super
controversial interview that i did with
him about his upcoming book called
extraterrestrial which will blow your
mind because he takes a position that
science is going off the rails and
actually we need to look to the heavens
perhaps to this object that he spotted
uh along with colleagues called omua mua
which is fun to say it's a hawaiian word
and look forward to conversations with
him stay tuned for i have a conversation
with leonard malone now that's on the
show about stephen hawking and then
hawking incorporated the business of
stephen hawking coming up soon as well
as a conversation with carlo rovelli let
me know if you want me to make that a
live stream i haven't decided yet would
you guys like to talk to carlo live
in a format like this he's generously
agreed to come on not once but twice let
me know if you want to have a
conversation with him live and ask
questions i'm so sorry i didn't get to
take too many of your questions today i
do read each and every comment so please
do that please subscribe to the podcast
on itunes it's a little bit different
than this one
uh and you can uh skip over all the
annoying ads that youtube presents to
you but uh for now i want to thank you
all for going into the impossible it's
been quite a joy to be with my friends
garrett lisey dr garrett lisey dr eric
weinstein two mavericks that lie outside
the traditional academia
role as i am blessed to be within
and uh and i and i appreciate them for
the uh for the integrity that they have
i may not agree with them as you noticed
on everything that they do but it's an
incredibly
vital
contribution to all the scientific
interests that i personally have and i
hope you have them too please subscribe
to the podcast as i said also don't miss
a special solo episode i did
about galileo's dialogue which i have
somewhere around here galileo's dialogue
is perhaps the most influential book in
human history at least from a scientific
perspective don't miss that
i did a solo episode about the great
galileo and i'm doing an audio book i
just got the rights to record the first
ever audiobook galileo and i'm having a
couple of my italian colleagues and i
are recording the first audiobook in
history
with authentic italian voices hopefully
it'll be a nice kind of theatrical
presentation i hope you'll like that for
now check that out check out on prager
university uh i did a book club with
michael moles uh who is controversial
but we only got into the scientific
aspects of things stay tuned for that
and uh and other many many great guests
as i said let me know should i have more
live stream conversations even if it
means i don't get to all your questions
let me know in the comments section for
now signing off
it's been a long four hours almost a
podcasting today i am tired and but my
mind is active i hope yours is too stay
tuned briankeating.com get on my mailing
list i'll send you a couple of awesome
free gifts such as uh such as the
astronomical great debate that we did
last year with nobel laureates including
uh david adam reese and also friends
like wendy friedman and others and i'll
also send you my life hacks from jim
simons and michael saylor and many
others for now signing off good night
and good luck as they used to say out
there in the multiverse of minds that we
connect together on the into the
impossible podcast good night everybody